it's okay to be comfortable it's not
okay to be small being too small in life
telling yourself that you should be
small that's the number one issue
shrinking yourself you see I for the
last couple years every single January I
have taught a course about the science
of dreaming and not just dreaming but
dreaming big and dreaming big as a way
to create a whole new chapter in your
life a way to tap into your potential
and more than 200 000 people around the
world have taken this science of
dreaming course with me and here's the
number one thing that I noticed after
teaching this course over and over and
over again to people around the world
it's that telling yourself that you're
small putting a lid on your own dreams
on your own potential that's the biggest
problem if you're somebody who doesn't
know what you want I guarantee you it's
because you do things that make you feel
small and then you tell yourself that's
okay hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need it I need it
for me because I don't wake up every day
and say yes let's go conquer the world
now I wake up and and I need that
external motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so it's today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Mel Robbins enjoy
and here's the thing that I'm really
worried about
I'm worried about the fact that if you
continue to do this if you continue to
tell yourself I don't know what I want I
can never have it I'm 46. I tried it's
hard it's not going to work out for me
if you are the one that is against your
big dreams in life
that is the reason why you're unhappy
that you are the single biggest loudest
voice for why you can't have what you
deserve
that is the source of misery that is the
source of feeling lost
and so
we got to stop that right now
because the fact is I don't care how
long you've worked on your dreams how
long you've avoided your dreams how long
you've been scared of your dreams how
long you've downplayed your dreams those
dreams are still very much alive inside
of you
you're not supposed to be small you're
not supposed to be arguing against your
dreams let other people do that you're
the one who's supposed to have the
biggest and the loudest and the
brightest voice when it comes to the
matter of your dreams there's one habit
that will change your life just one
and it is do not sleep with your phone
because the one decision everybody makes
that kills your productivity kills your
focus tanks your mental health is before
you get yourself right you grab your
phone and check in with the world and
that means you gave your most important
commodity your time and your attention
to things that don't matter what should
you do with that 10 minutes do you think
use a five second rule five four three
two one get out of bed do not lay there
like a human pot roast marinating in
fear staring at the ceiling get out of
bed second thing I want you to do make
your bed wait don't it snooze though can
you no you shouldn't and there's a
there's actually a neurological reason
oh so people who hit the snooze button
based on the research when you drift
back into sleep it triggers your brain
to go into a sleep cycle that typically
lasts between 75 and 90 minutes and when
the alarm goes back off in five minutes
five minutes you're in what they call a
state of sleep inertia oh so you're all
oh it impacts your productivity for four
hours okay so don't do that okay then
make your bed make your bed because it
is a way to keep a small promise to
yourself it's also a way to have a nice
place to come back to like a gift
tonight it's a simple way to build a
little discipline the third thing I want
you to do when you go to the bathroom is
I want you to look in the mirror and I
want you to add a high five in the
mirror to your morning routine a high
five to yourself yes okay there's a
reason why okay we did this massive
study 50 of men and women cannot look at
themselves in the mirror in the morning
and the rest of us glance at ourselves
in the mirror and focus on what we hate
if you physically raise your hand
without saying a word and you raise your
hand to the mirror something crazy
happens a lifetime of positive
neurological programming that has been
attached to the act of giving a high
five to other people gets aimed back at
you wow the next thing I want you to do
is simply take five minutes the
remaining five minutes they have and do
some kind of mindset practice and as the
close of the practice before you look at
your phone I want you to decide what is
one thing
that matters to me today that I'm going
to make progress on that's it how do you
stop procrastinating oh
simple just nail yourself to a chair
that's what you do you tell yourself no
booze until you get it done that works
no it doesn't the reason why these
things don't work is because most of us
don't even understand what
procrastination is I know I certainly
didn't
the reason why you procrastinate is not
why you think
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
procrastination is a stress reliever
that's right it's a tool that you use to
give yourself relief from stress that
you feel and the stress that you may be
feeling right now might be stressed
about money you might be stressed about
your health maybe you're stressed about
something going on at work or about a
relationship that you're in and the way
that this relates to procrastination is
you're stressed out you got work you
know you need to do but instead of doing
it you go online or you watch the
highlights of last night's game or you
waste an hour looking at Facebook and
when you do that when you avoid work
makes you feel good but just for a
minute
see this is where we get procrastination
all wrong a lot of people think
procrastination is about willpower it
means that you're lazy has nothing to do
with that it's all about your stress
that's why your work ethic or discipline
that's not that's not going to solve
this either the key to stopping
procrastination number one is
understanding what it is it's a way that
you deal with stress and number two it's
about five second decisions that stop
the cycle of procrastinating because
when you change your decisions you're
going to change everything and here's
how you're going to use the five second
rule to do it
when you catch yourself procrastinating
or you feel yourself starting to avoid
what you need to do
use the rule
54321 activate your prefrontal cortex
and then acknowledge acknowledge that
you feel stressed out that's the first
piece then you're going to use the five
second rule to just get started that's
it for five minutes that's all I'm
asking force yourself I'm stressed out I
get it but I'm going to work for five
minutes five four three two one sit down
and get started
after you've worked for five minutes
give yourself a break watch all the cat
videos you want I don't really care
the point here is that this is a way
that you can use the five second rule in
combination with research about beating
procrastination that puts you in control
of your decisions use the alarm on your
phone
seriously this is this is a genius hack
put the alarm on your phone to use to
help you be your future self it's like a
it's like a reminder from the Future
Okay cakes done get up go check on it no
seriously so every single smartphone has
the ability to set an alarm and on the
alarm when you go to set the time
there's a there's a label
right now it says alarm you can
literally change the label to help you
remember anything
and here's what's super cool about a
simple alarm in your phone research has
found that twice as many people who
received quit smoking messages quit
smoking over a six-month period
so these little systems like setting an
alarm in your phone whether you're
reminding yourself to take the vitamins
that you want to be taking or you're
reminding yourself to get outside for
the run or you're reminding yourself to
spend 30 minutes working on a project
that you wanted to get done
they're gonna make you based on the
research twice as successful twice more
likely this simple stuff works
and it's not that hard
let's I it's not that hard right not
that hard to put a Post-It note on the
mirror not that hard to set an alarm in
your phone not that hard to set the
water bottle out but you got to do it
okay
simple systems work
because your life is complicated enough
and if you can put that Post-It note up
you are setting yourself up for Success
I'm telling you it's true also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there it's really hard to find the
courage
to make a decision
that is the right decision for you
and it's hard because we are so quick to
consider what everybody else is thinking
we're so quick to weigh how our decision
is going to impact somebody else's
feelings that's why we don't trust our
gut we all know we need to trust our gut
that's like that's duh
the thing is how
and so take away number one that I want
you to leave with is stop saying trust
your gut and start saying I need to have
the courage
to make decisions that are right for me
second
feeling feeling
give yourself the ability and the time
and the the quiet to drop into your body
and feel whether or not
the decision or the direction opens up
possibility
makes you feel like you're growing and
thriving it levels you up it may be
scary as hell I mean think about Amy's
Story how the hell are you gonna like do
12 months of Revenue in one month you
just declared that who the [__] does
that you do
if it feels like a part of you is
opening up there you go there's your
decision if it feels like a part of you
is shrinking oh I'm going here because
everybody in my family went here I'm a
doctor because everybody in my family is
a doctor I live here because everybody
lives here that's not the right decision
and finally
when you do drop in and you allow
yourself to step onto a tour with the
future you
you're going to feel the no first listen
to it
you're gonna feel the yes because it
feels like an opening
find the courage Alana said in her
opening sentence to me I'm scared of the
rejection I will face when I start
making choices for the new me you know I
read something interesting and I want to
tell you this before I forget it and
then I'm going to talk generally about
friendship hoping that the way that I'm
thinking about friendship will help you
lose the guilt number one
um this kind this came from a book that
my husband was reading about alcohol and
it really made me stop and think and
that is this when you decide that you
don't want to drink for whatever reason
what's interesting about being somebody
that doesn't drink at a party is that
the only person that gives us what's in
your glass is you nobody else typically
cares but the thing that's interesting
is that when somebody says to you would
you like a drink and you say no I'm not
drinking I'm not drinking for the month
of January or no I'm sober or not you
know I don't feel like it what happens
is the fact that you're turning down the
alcohol it can actually magnify by
somebody else's struggle with their own
decisions around it and so the first
thing that I want to point out is if you
have friends that make you wrong for
changing your life for the better that's
their issue it's not yours and so you
gotta untangle the fact that they have
baggage about getting in shape or they
have baggage about going to the bar
that's theirs and it has nothing to do
with the decisions that you're making so
if your friends in general give you
blowback for changing for the better
what you need to say in the back of your
mind is interesting they're obviously
very conflicted about their choice to go
to the bar and drink every night but
that has nothing to do with me here's
the other thing you can do if they start
to make you wrong you can say well you
want to go to Planet Fitness with me
instead it doesn't sound like you want
to be at the bar so that said let me
talk to you a little bit about friends
friends are people that you care about
and I have this test I call it the
funeral test if somebody in your life
were to die ask yourself would I go to
to their funeral if the answer is yes
they're a friend of yours that's the
test for whether or not in my opinion
someone is a friend because it means you
care about them now here's the other
thing about friendship that I want you
to understand you can care about
somebody and not like hanging out with
them and that's the situation that
you're in right now that you have plenty
of friends that you care about if they
were to die you would go to their
funeral if they needed you you would be
there if you saw them you'd be happy to
see them but you don't like to hang out
with them the other thing that I want
you to think about is that and that's
okay that's like a normal part of
friendship and the reason why that's a
normal part of friendship is because one
of the things that we know about life is
that you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain patterns right in the
old chapter of your life you would go to
the bar and drink you would go to the
store and spend money you didn't have
you're in a new chapter now and so you
have different patterns when your life
takes on different patterns whether it's
you're no longer going to the bar you're
going to the gem the pattern might even
be that one of your kids is playing with
a different soccer team or maybe you've
moved to a different street in your town
when the patterns change so will your
circle of friends it's a fact of life
but that doesn't mean your old friends
the ones that you used to drink with
aren't friends anymore it just means
that you don't want to hang out with
them you still care about them but you
don't like doing what they do in terms
of my own experience with getting
serious about creating the skill of
confidence is it's a game changer
the more that you build confidence in
your life the greater the risks you're
going to take and that's critical in
business in life for fulfillment I also
have the ability to say no and not even
be bothered by what other people are
going to feel why because I have the
skill of confidence it also makes you an
incredible negotiator because you
realize you would rather be respected
than be liked and see this kind of need
to be liked or to look good is part of
the reason why you doubt yourself all
the time I want you to bring that power
back internally that's what the skill of
confidence does and you'll also be able
to recognize when you're afraid of
something and that that fear is just
kind of [__] in your head and you
have a choice you don't have to let fear
stop you anymore and that's where the
skill of confidence comes in and the
same is going to be true for you
so I think it kind of begs the question
if confidence is something that we all
want why is it so hard to master I'll
tell you why
because when it comes to the research
around confidence it is some of the most
dry
boring no offense to the confidence
researchers and writers out there but
I'm talking if you have trouble sleeping
just print out a study about confidence
that'll that that'll put you into deep
REM sleep it's also confusing and even
Google isn't much of a help on this
topic if you search how to be confident
you know what the top results one of
them says be true to you what the hell
does that even mean be true to you and
honestly be true to you that is not what
the research says the problem and why
it's hard for people to develop the
skill of confidence is the research has
not been boiled down into tactical
information that you can apply to your
day-to-day life and that's where your
friend Mel Robbins comes in so here's
your first assignment on today's podcast
because you know we're not just
listening here this is a doing podcast
and we're going to make this tactical
and relevant immediately
assignment number one be selfish as you
listen I want you to listen a particular
way I want you to listen and think
what's in it for me and so let me ask
you a question to help you get really
selfish
if you had more confidence like I could
go
and boom you have more confidence than
you've ever had in your entire life
how would your life be different
how would your future be different
now Heather has already shared that she
has this awesome promotion which she
clearly earned I mean businesses don't
just give those out as Charity if a
business has promoted or hired you they
believe in your ability to execute but
now she's freaking out
she doesn't have the confidence
now when you think about confidence
how would more confidence help Heather's
life be different well confidence would
allow Heather to step into that role
right and she would be able to lose the
self-doubt and the Imposter syndrome and
the panicking and she'd be able to act
like the leader that the organization
promoted her to be right without all the
like nervousness and crap going on in
her head what about you let's get
selfish
what would more confidence allow you to
do that you're not currently doing
would you be able to say no
would you be better with boundaries are
there more risks you would take is there
a conversation you've been avoiding with
yourself or someone else would you be
able to stand up for yourself Advocate
more for yourself ask for what you need
what about work would you be more
visible would you speak up more all of
that that you just envisioned it's all
within your reach I want you to know
that when you have the revelation
that the voice that you've listened to
for years
the voice that's held you back that made
you feel like that it's actually not
even yours
that can make your heart seize for a
minute
it's kind of one of those like wait wait
what
and then when I add on top of it that
you're not to blame
for the crap that somebody programmed
into your head
you were just a little person with three
pounds of macaroni that was trying to
absorb everything around it and our
brains love patterns and it picks up on
patterns of speaking
and
that's what your brain did
and so if you're having this Revelation
holy [__]
I've thought that everything's my fault
for my entire life
because somebody made me believe it was
and then I held on to that belief
don't freak out
this is great news because so many
people spend their entire lives not even
realizing that it's possible
to change the way you think
it is possible to put a new playlist in
your mind it is possible to filter the
world completely differently and to make
your brain work for you now are you
going to have positive thoughts all day
long no
are you gonna be like you know
a thousand percent confident no
but can you stop torturing yourself
yes
can you start encouraging yourself you
better believe you can
can you separate what your narcissistic
piece of ex-spouse said to you
from what you actually believe about
yourself
that you want to believe about yourself
yeah you can
you do it overnight no
you're gonna have to work at this just
like
the people in your past worked over time
at saying things to you that beat you
down so my biggest struggle now is doing
creating self-love for myself without
feeling guilty without feeling like I'm
not being humble enough or without
feeling like I'm less of a mother or
less of a wife because I'm taking care
of myself
um I know it's the other way I know that
I have to take care of me so I can take
care of others but I just have a hard
time doing it without feeling that guilt
Janet I got some bad news
you can't remove the guild
I'm gonna say that again
when you first start putting yourself
first you will not remove the guilt
and so I just want to be honest about
that but let me give you the two
takeaways okay that are really important
because this really isn't about guilt
this is about you defining for yourself
what it means to be a good wife and a
good mother and a good person in your
eyes and so I'm going to give you two
major wake-up calls that I had around
this topic and then I'm going to tell
you this crazy story so the first
wake-up call that I got is this notion
that the people who love you
they will be annoyed with you when you
put yourself first it is true they are
not going to like it they like you being
the person that you are right now it is
convenient for them that you put them
first it is wonderful the dynamic that's
in place but it's no longer good for you
so just expect that the people who you
love will be annoyed or disappointed or
upset when you start putting yourself
first
but they're still going to love you
it's not an either or thing and I'll
explain more about that
and second this is a huge wake-up call
what if the guilt doesn't go away
what if guilt is actually a good thing
what if guilt is super healthy to feel
right now
in fact that's what I believe
I believe that the guilt is good I
believe that the guilt is healthy and I
believe that you can reframe it
see Guilt shows that you care that's why
you feel that way if you are a
narcissistic douchebag you wouldn't feel
guilty at all for putting yourself first
I want to frame guilt in a different way
for you okay
let's frame it from a bad sign oh I'm
doing something bad I'm putting myself
first into a good one stop seeing guilt
is a bad thing because you're not doing
anything wrong when you put yourself
first
start seeing guilt as a good thing guilt
is a sign that you're breaking free of
this people-pleasing habit
you feel guilty because putting yourself
first is just a new feeling that's it
you know I had this Insight a few years
ago that I think might help you
two things can be true in life at the
same time
you can put yourself first and
disappoint people
and they can still love you even though
they're disappointed
and here's another example of how two
things can be true at the same time you
can feel guilty
and you can still put yourself first
pretty cool it's not an either or
and that's why I say that this topic
about people pleasing is about balancing
your needs with the fact that in order
to have great relationships you do have
to compromise sometimes and the balance
comes in because in order for you to
have the life that you want you are
going to disappoint people that you love
sometimes confidence is not a Feeling
confidence is embodied in action
my definition of confidence is
confidence is the willingness to try
I'm going to say it again
your new definition of confidence
embodied by the research
confidence is the willingness to try
confidence is an action that's what it
is
and this phenomenon has been heavily
researched by social psychologists and
there's even a term for confidence being
an action see there's this positive
feedback loop that happens when you're
willing to try something before you feel
ready when you're willing to step into
that leadership role and put yourself
out there and take risks and make
mistakes and shove that self-doubt to
the side when you're willing to try
Neuroscience research says that you
create something called a confidence
confidence Loop and let me explain this
to you because there's a lot of common
sense here right
every single time you try something new
you're either going to be really good at
it or you're going to be terrible at it
right
but you always learn something
but you have to try you might be really
good at it when you start trying to set
them you might be really miserable at it
but here's the thing if you try
something for the first time
you're either going to fail or succeed
but you always learn something and
that's where this confidence competence
Loop and the Neuroscience research comes
in because even when you try
when you learn a little something you
gain a little competency right because
of everything that you learned the first
time around
it gets a little bit easier it gets a
little bit better but it all begins with
being willing to try no matter where
you're starting from because if you are
the kind of person that's always willing
to try you will always grow and you will
always learn and the more that you try
and the more that you learn the less you
doubt yourself the less resistance that
you have and bada bang bada boom all of
a sudden you feel confident in this new
role all of a sudden you feel confident
doing a backflip off a boat because you
tried a thousand times and your belly
flopped and you embarrassed yourself and
you got a wedgie and then what do you
know because you were willing to keep
trying all of that competency that got
gained of trying over and over and over
and over again it's how you gained
mastery
see feeling confident
is kind of
um it's it's almost like the wrong way
to say it
because that's what you feel after
you've done it over and over and over
again but true confidence Begins the
moment you're willing to try Sarah's
question was this are there ways to
unlock sudden rapid steps to big change
in a short period of time or is this a
dangerous misconception
now I said yes
there is a way for you to experience big
change in a short period of time
if you change how you view yourself
I mean that's the biggest kind of change
that you can experience
when you change your identity when you
change what you believe is possible
that's transformational
now one other thing that Sarah said
though is she asked is it a dangerous
misconception
to think that big change happens
immediately
and that brings me to the topic of
habits
see change doesn't happen overnight
but when you understand the science of
habits what you realize is that change
little change it compounds daily
and the massive change that you
experience in a short period of time
when you focus on habit formation is how
you relate to yourself so I'm going to
give you an example let's say that you
set a goal that this is the year that
you are going to run your first marathon
you're going to train for it you're
going to finish the race
now it will take time it's going to take
you time to achieve that goal but if you
make it a habit to wake up every day and
get out the door and go for that
training run within a matter of days
something kind of crazy happens
you experience this massive change
because you start to see yourself
differently
you start to see yourself as a runner
now have you achieved that goal yet no
that's going to take time
but the power of habits is that as you
practice them they start to change your
identity they become evidence that
you're the kind of person that goes for
a run so in the beginning habits are
just something that you and I do but
over it but over time
habits change who you are you do have
the power to create a better life you
are not meant to White Knuckle your way
through this thing you're not meant to
be in survival mode you deserve to be a
happier person and you are capable of
identifying your goals and chipping away
at them and you are capable my friend of
dreaming big and once you can visualize
those big dreams of yours you can put
your head down and you can make those
things happen if you're willing to put
in the work I want you to imagine a
brand new possibility for your life
and if you like Sarah can say I want to
be happy I want the next chapter of my
life to be amazing if you can just even
start there
all you have to do is start to think
about what kind of a map do you need in
order to chart a course to make that
possibility that you see for your life a
reality
and I love this topic of reinvention I
love it love it love it because I have
this metaphor that I've been using for
years when it comes to understanding
reinvention
and what is the metaphor
the metaphor that I use is a road trip
that's right
life is one big road trip and we're
going to use this metaphor of a road
trip to demystify the entire concept and
process of Reinventing yourself or
Reinventing Your Life And for those of
you that have listened to my number one
ranked audio series on Audible called
reinventure life you have heard me talk
about this metaphor and this is such a
powerful concept because the fact is
life is a journey
it's one big road trip and for too many
of us that road trip is boring and
monotonous and I want to shake things up
I want your life to be the most exciting
exhilarating amazing road trip that you
could possibly imagine and we're all on
this big road trip we all began at the
exact same mile marker zero
every single year of your life is
another mile marker on this twisting
amazing journey called life for me I'm
at mild marker 54. that is how far down
the road I am and so I want you to stop
and just think okay well what mile
marker am I at right now and it's a
useful exercise to think about it that
way because when I say to you hey
I'm at mile marker 54. that tells me
that there's a lot of road that I've
covered behind me but guess what
there is a huge open road ahead of me
and when you take responsibility
for charting that course of where that
open road is going to lead you
you take control of your life that's
what reinvention is all about it's about
creating a map picking a destination and
charting your course on this road called
life and here's what's exciting about
that you get to choose you get to choose
how fast you're going to drive whether
you're going to take the highway whether
you're going to twist and turn where you
want to go next I know that I have to
take care of me so I can take care of
others but I just have a hard time doing
it without feeling that guilt to me it
literally feels like a child learning to
walk I don't know how to do it without
feeling guilt I want to remove that
guilt from inside of me Janet I got some
bad news
you can't remove the guilt
I must say that again
when you first start putting yourself
first you will not remove the guilt
and so I just want to be honest about
that but let me give you the two
takeaways okay that are really important
because this really isn't about guilt
this is about you defining for yourself
what it means to be a good wife and a
good mother and a good person in your
eyes and so I'm going to give you two
major wake-up calls that I had around
this topic and then I'm going to tell
you this crazy story so the first
wake-up call that I got is this notion
that the people who love you
they will be annoyed with you when you
put yourself first it is true they are
not going to like it they like you being
the person that you are right now it is
convenient for them that you put them
first it is wonderful the dynamic that's
in place but it's no longer good for you
so just expect that the people who you
love will be annoyed or disappointed or
upset when you start putting yourself
first
but they're still going to love you
it's not an either or thing and I'll
explain more about that
and second this is a huge wake-up call
what if the guilt doesn't go away
what if guilt is actually a good thing
what if guilt is super healthy to feel
right now
in fact that's what I believe
I believe that the guilt is good I
believe that the guilt is healthy and I
believe that you can reframe it
see Guilt shows that you care that's why
you feel that way if you were a
narcissistic douchebag you wouldn't feel
guilty at all for putting yourself first
I want to frame guilt in a different way
for you okay
let's frame it from a bad sign oh I'm
doing something bad I'm putting myself
first into a good one stop seeing guilt
is a bad thing because you're not doing
anything wrong when you put yourself
first
start seeing guilt as a good thing guilt
is a sign that you're breaking free of
this people-pleasing habit
you feel guilty because putting yourself
first is just a new feeling that's it I
love my morning routine so much I call
it the million dollar morning because it
is in fact the morning routine that
makes me feel like a million bucks it
gives me laser focus it helps me make
progress and it is the structure and
Foundation upon which I chip away at my
goals and I stay consistent and I have
built the business and continue to build
the business that I have built that life
that you envision you're capable of
achieving it you can do the work to make
that version of yourself a reality but
it's not going to happen out of thin air
you gotta put in the work and I
personally believe that that work begins
first thing in the morning that every
single morning you can wake up and
experience a clean slate you can wake up
and you can create a morning routine not
that the you right now likes but the
morning routine that the future you
needs and the bottom line is
whether you consider yourself to be a
morning person or not
a morning routine is essential a morning
routine is like the first Domino
let's just agree that every single day
of your life you wake up and you have
the opportunity to create a new
experience in your life
and that first series of decisions that
you make
which are basically your morning routine
it's like the beginning Domino that
falls
and if your morning routine sucks like
my morning routine used to suck the
first Domino that falls in your day is
procrastination stress anxiety
depression suckiness and that tends to
trigger a whole lot more of that
now let's talk about the other option
have you ever had a morning where you
rolled out of bed because you had to be
somewhere
you actually met a friend at the gym
and the exercise class
was not only not that bad it was kind of
fun
and you felt really energized and proud
of yourself for going
and you were set up for the meeting that
you had you were prepared what's it like
when that Domino Falls it feels good
doesn't it it makes you feel confident
and alive and proud of yourself it kind
of creates this energy and this Motion
in your life
and that brings me to a simple statement
the solution to almost all the problems
in your life
is your morning routine
if you were to get serious
about creating a morning routine that
makes you feel like a million bucks that
sets you up with the structure and
momentum and Positive Choices that act
like a domino that send you into your
day feeling like you have started the
day off with a bang checking the right
boxes getting it done feeling proud
putting yourself first
imagine how the rest of your day flows
you see how you set your day up is how
it ends up say it again
how you set your day up is how it ends
up
and if you are serious about making more
money or making change stick or getting
things done or just feeling happier or
finally learning how to put yourself on
the list let's get laser focused on your
morning routine
because when you get laser focused on
your morning routine and setting
yourself up for Success from the get-go
it's pretty amazing What flows from
there what is an anchor thought
anchor thought is a extremely powerful
and proven way
for you to take control of what you're
thinking about
when your mind starts to spiral
and an anchor thought is any thought
that makes you excited
happy
think positive emotions here I'm going
to give you examples don't worry
um an anchor thought is something that
you have predetermined and planned in
advance that you're going to go to in
your mind and picture this is like a
form of visualization
in a situation where normally you feel
anxiety and you're you going to use this
practice of having a predetermined
anchor thought in situations that make
you nervous or anxious to go to
as a method to Anchor yourself down
to calm down your body and to take
control of what you're thinking about in
situations that normally make you
anxious the way that I started using
anchor thoughts in order to change the
way that I thought and felt on a plane
is this
I would think about before I got on a
plane I would think about something
that I was excited to do once I got to
the place that I was flying to so for
example tomorrow I am flying to Vegas
and I'm going to think about
a particular restaurant that I love in
Vegas and I'm going to think about what
I'm going to order when I get to that
restaurant and I'm going to think about
how delicious it's going to taste and
this person my friend MO that I'm gonna
see and so I've got my anchor thought
which makes me happy and excited what
I'm going to do when I get to Vegas and
when I get on that plane
and if I start to get nervous and my
stomach starts to rumble and my body
starts to feel anxious and my thoughts
start to spiral
I immediately start saying to myself I
am so excited
to get to Vegas and to go to that
restaurant and to see my friend MO and
notice him closing my eyes because I'm
visualizing it and I'm visualizing how
happy I'm going to be when I see her and
that very specific positive excited
happy visualization of what I'm going to
do when I get to Vegas
it Shadows my body having that in my
mind
it
focuses my mind on something positive
and I by using an anchor thought to
weigh me down in terms of way down what
I'm thinking about
and
um
direct My Body Sensations to be positive
I woke up this morning and I was feeling
really anxious
and what that means for me is the second
that I wake up my heart is racing
and I start feeling like something's
wrong
and I know this feeling because I've had
anxiety for decades
it doesn't come around that much anymore
but when it does takes me right back
so I wanted to just grab the phone and
show you what I do when I wake up
feeling anxious first of all rule number
one do not under any circumstances lay
in bed if you wake up and you feel
anxious about something you have got to
use the five second rule five four three
two one get up
get out of bed
get moving because if you can get up you
can get going if you can get going you
can get dressed if you can get dressed
you can move your body if you can move
your body you can then move your
emotions if you can move your emotions
you can then move your mind if you can
move your mind you can move your mood so
one thing leads to another number one
get up I think you should Chase what
energizes you everyone talks about
passion Legacy purpose
the one word to pay attention to is
energy I love that that's it let's
simplify this okay so
whatever energizes you naturally expands
you feels like possibility is exciting
to do it may be scary that doesn't
matter it has to do with how it makes
you feel right when you were in your 20s
money made you feel good it expanded you
it energized you chasing the money that
was the game that was your passion that
was your per there's nothing wrong with
that nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are watching yeah because it
is socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what ha
and and the reason why I say that is
because people talk about the word
passion yeah or purpose right
and the truth is it's not a person place
or a thing it's not
it is
the feeling of being expanded and
energized right if you're pursuing your
passion it means that you wake up every
day and are energized so instead of
trying to think what's my purpose what's
my passion what's my purpose what's my
passion
yeah instead of thinking like that I
want you instead to ask yourself what's
what could I do today that would
energize me what energizes me if it's
making money
figure out how to make money right if it
is making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's [__] thrilling yeah but
what happens is once you learn how to do
something once you can do it over and
over again and so it starts to become
routine yeah which means it's no longer
energizing right which is why every
entrepreneur out there goes through the
mode of chasing the money and then you
hit the money that you need to make then
you're like I'm not fulfilled what type
of purpose I don't know what to do yeah
you know I did the everybody does yeah
and it's because you were energized by
the money and now you're not yeah now
you got to be energized by the next
thing yeah and for you it's clearly
service it's clearly making a difference
it's empowering others and so when I
look back on my trajectory yeah the
thing that energizes me
is making people
feel like they matter oh yeah
it's that simple it is giving people
hope
in a situation where they don't have it
it is shining a light on the path
forward when somebody feels stuck in
darkness it's very easy to see where you
doubt yourself but it's super hard to
come up with the alternative thought
that you're going to substitute
well the reason why it's hard is because
you actually believe these thoughts
and these thoughts have become patterns
and they've become habits and they've
become so uh prevalent in your life that
they're almost like the co-host
of your life
um you know if you think about it you
are the star of your life but if the
supporting actor is a limiting belief
that constantly tells you that you're
not good enough or that you're not
worthy or that you'll never succeed then
it's no wonder that you believe it
because the co-star of your life is your
limiting beliefs and so it's not
easy
to change your limiting beliefs but it
is simple
and it begins with you identifying them
and then substituting them so the most I
think effective way of beginning the
process of teaching yourself how to
identify a limiting belief and then come
up with your own
substitute positive belief as a way to
change the negative pattern in your mind
is to use the power of objectivity
so write down all your limiting beliefs
and I'm going to go through this in
detail in just a second write down all
your learning English I'm not worthy I'm
not good enough nothing works out for me
nobody's gonna love me whatever it is
that you think that's that's bringing
you down and then you can ask yourself
this what would Mel say
if Mal were sitting here across from me
what would Mel say
another thing you can do you can write
the opposite of what you're thinking why
are habits awesome I'll tell you why
habits are awesome because when a
behavior becomes automatic there's zero
drama in your life it's just so much
easier like I'll give you my husband the
man is Mr habit he just rolls out of bed
like nothing's happened he gets up he
gets dressed he meditates he goes to the
gym he walks the dog he journals
he does it automatically
no drama
there are certainly areas in my life
where I would love to be less dramatic
less emotional less resistant to the
things that I want to do I'd love to
just sort of roll through it like my
husband does
and so lets you and I
let's not just make this like a
conversation let's move from listening
to doing
if I could take a science-back magic
wand
and I could remove all the resistance
that you feel in your body
what is one Behavior change that you
would like to make
one new habit or you know sometimes it's
easier to say what's a bad habit you'd
like to break do you chew your nails
do you
hit the snooze button five times
said in the positive what's a new habit
you'd like to create
would you like to
exercise every day
do you want to get your finances in
order and be more responsible with money
I'm going to give you a few examples
okay
would you love to be the kind of person
we're part of your routine is to get
outside and exercise every day
or how about the kind of person who
keeps your room or your desk clean or
you have a zero inbox that'd be pretty
awesome
would you like to be the kind of person
that gets up 30 minutes earlier than you
do right now just rolls right out of bed
like my husband does
or how about the kind of person who
feels comfortable in Social settings
you push yourself out there a little bit
more
you uh you know push through that
discomfort you feel a little bit more
outgoing
maybe you want to make it a habit to
meditate and feel like you're the kind
of person that's more mindful
that's where the science of habits is so
important why do habits matter so much
I'll tell you why habits matter
you've learned one reason and that has
to do with identity right but the real
reason why habits matter
is because learning new habits are the
only way to go from what your day-to-day
life looks like right now
to something different
it's the only way
it's the bricks on the pathway to
changing your life that's what habits
are
and habits are evidence every time that
you get out that door and you go for the
run it's evidence that you are becoming
a particular type of person
the other reason why habits are so
important habits are so important
is because they make your life easier
I mean I want you to just stop and
consider something think about how hard
it is
to be the kind of person who has a habit
of hitting the snooze button four or
five times every morning
and then you drag yourself out of bed
that's a habit and you start your day
chronically late that's a habit I used
to do this I used to do this this was
the Mel Robbins that you did not know I
was a chronic snooze button hitter I
would drag myself out of bed by the time
I got out of bed the kids had missed the
bus I started the day behind it was a
nightmare it was so hard to have that
bad habit and in order to change I
needed to become a different person
I needed to become a person that got up
when the alarm rang that had a morning
routine and that organized my Mooring so
that I would begin the day with a sense
of accomplishment that's what I wanted
instead of beginning the day like I was
behind and I was already failing before
I got out of bed and the gateway to
making that change is changing your
habits in the morning
when you have habits that support you
and your goals and the kind of person
you want to become your life gets easier
and that's why habits truly matter we
all procrastinate we avoid the things
that we know that we need to do and then
we spend the rest of the day beating
ourselves up it's amazing actually it
sucks doesn't it so how do you stop
procrastinating oh
simple just nail yourself to a chair
that's what you do you tell yourself no
booze until you get it done that works
no it doesn't the reason why these
things don't work is because most of us
don't even understand what
procrastination is I know I certainly
didn't
the reason why you procrastinate is not
why you think
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
procrastination is a stress reliever
that's right it's a tool that you use to
give yourself relief from stress that
you feel and the stress that you may be
feeling right now might be stressed
about money you might be stressed about
your health maybe you're stressed about
something going on at work or about a
relationship that you're in
and the way that this relates to
procrastination is you're stressed out
you got work you know you need to do but
instead of doing it you go online or you
watch the highlights of last night's
game or you waste an hour looking at
Facebook and when you do that when you
avoid work makes you feel good
but just for a minute
see this is where we get procrastination
all wrong a lot of people think
procrastination is about willpower it
means that you're lazy has nothing to do
with that it's all about your stress
that's why your work ethic or discipline
that's not that's not going to solve
this either the key to stopping
procrastination number one is
understanding what it is it's a way that
you deal with stress and number two it's
about five second decisions that stop
the cycle of procrastinating because
when you change your decisions you're
going to change everything and here's
how you're going to use the five second
rule to do it
when you catch yourself procrastinating
or you feel yourself starting to avoid
what you need to do
use the rule
54321 activate your prefrontal cortex
and then acknowledge acknowledge that
you feel stressed out that's the first
piece then you're going to use the five
second rule to just get started that's
it for five minutes that's all I'm
asking force yourself I'm stressed out I
get it but I'm going to work for five
minutes five four three two one sit down
and get started after you've worked for
five minutes give yourself a break watch
all the cat videos you want I don't
really care
the point here is that this is a way
that you can use the five second rule in
combination with research about beating
procrastination that puts you in control
of your decisions
Stacy found that when she used the five
second rule to improve her relationship
with herself there was an amazing result
she stopped procrastinating in her words
your rule has helped me grow in ways I
never thought possible I no longer
procrastinate on anything and the same
is going to be true for you because when
you understand that procrastination is
something that you do when you're
stressed and you also understand that
the secret to beating procrastination
which is a habit
is to just get started now you can use
the five second rule to leverage all the
research that will help you end the
habit of procrastinating once and for
all anxiety
if this is the first time you're
thinking about it
anxiety is what happens when you are
worrying about something in the future
that makes you feel uncertain
or makes you feel like you're going to
lose control that's it
anxiety is when you start worrying about
things in the future that make you feel
uncertain or make you feel like you're
about to lose control and you start to
get stomach ache or you start to feel
tightness in your throat or you start to
shake your hands or you start to have
your heart race or you start to have
sweaty ponds your body starts to get
agitated because you're really busy
worrying about the test tomorrow you're
really busy worrying about whether or
not you're going to throw up you're
really busy worrying about that
sleepover and whether or not it's going
to go okay you're really busy worrying
about whether or not your friends are
going to talk to you when you walk into
school today or you're busy worrying
that something might happen to your
parents why did I give you those
examples there was a specific reason why
the top worries that kids 12 and under
have are number one throwing up now why
would throwing up cause kids anxiety
because as an adult you've probably done
it a bunch and so you know that you
throw up it's over it sucks but that's
it there's no sense getting yourself
worked up about it but for kids this is
the number one thing that kids are
afraid of because it is an enormous loss
of control when it happens and it scares
a lot of kids to have that happening to
them because their brains aren't matured
and they don't understand that it's just
a moment so they're not actually worried
about the throwing up
they're having anxiety because they're
thinking that it could happen at some
point and that makes their body feel
weird and then of course because their
body feels weird it makes them certain
that it's coming I mean kids can
actually I have a son that actually made
himself throw up because he got so
worked up thinking that he might
that he caused himself to this is a true
story absolutely true story so I have
lived this
um being worried about you dying
major cause of worry for kids they think
about it and if they think about it too
much and they don't have a process and a
plan around how to live with that very
normal fear it will turn into anxiety
the social pressures are being accepted
going to a sleepover and being worried
about what's going to happen because
you've never been to the house before
you don't really like dogs and they have
one your friend's dad kind of scares you
what time are we going to go to bed you
see there's a lot of uncertainty that we
adults don't think about when it relates
to sleepovers at new friends houses that
your kids are worrying about and if they
stay up here and they start worrying
about all the uncertainty it's going to
cause their body to start to freak out
and then the whole thing starts to
spiral and next thing you don't they
don't want to go or they get there and
they're on edge and they need to come
home again we've had that situation in
our family too where the inability to
tolerate the uncertainty of something
that's supposed to be fun when am I
going to bed what are we going to eat
will I throw up on there are they going
to like me what are their parents like
what TV are we going to watch what time
are you picking me up in the morning all
of those unanswered questions and the
inability to tolerate the uncertainty of
that triggers the anxiety in your kids
this is what's happening in their brains
the rejection of friends you know the
the group dynamics of kids particularly
in Middle School brutal you couldn't pay
me millions of dollars to go back to
Middle School at this point but your
kids are walking into it every day and
they're worrying about whether or not
they're being accepted because every
moment in school is a moment of
uncertainty about whether or not you're
going to get the answer right whether or
not people are going to laugh whether or
not you're wearing the right things and
so again these are all the things that
trigger
your child to worry because they are
racked with situations that cause
uncertainty and that make our kids feel
like they might lose control now here's
the major mistake that you and I make as
parents
when our kids start to worry or when our
kids start to feel anxious which is the
agitation in their body you know what
you and I immediately do we immediately
try to fix it we swoop right in and we
start to either say you're going to be
okay and we assure them because we're
trying to fix it right we're trying to
make the worry go away we say oh well
this is going to happen and that's going
to happen and this is going to happen
and so we answer all their Pro and we
start to put in all kinds of certainty
for them
and that is the exact opposite thing
that you and I should be doing
and it's not our fault we've kind of
been doing it forever haven't we I mean
we're always worried about our kids and
so we put up gates at the top of stairs
so if they don't fall down we've got
child locks uncapped so that they don't
eat anything we stop buying the Tide
Pods because we didn't want them to
choke on it like as parents we're
constantly anticipating things that
could go wrong we're putting in controls
and so it is natural for you and me to
jump into Fix-It mode if you want to
get your kid
to move beyond the grip of anxiety you
have to understand how your behavior is
contributing
to the anxiety itself
see one of the things that I believe
about anxiety is the reason why we
develop it and the reason why we keep it
around is because it works I mean if
your kid is anxious and they start
freaking out they don't have to go to
school so all of a sudden that situation
that they felt uncomfortable around
they've now gained control because the
anxiety worked you swooped in you fixed
it you said that's okay you don't have
to go
and the problem with doing this is that
we might be managing the momentary
breakdown
but we are not teaching our kids a
critical skill in life and that is the
ability the ability to tolerate not
knowing
and the ability in the face of not
knowing to assure yourself that no
matter what you'll figure it out that is
one of the most critical things that you
could teach your kids the self-reliance
the resiliency the courage and the
confidence to know that even though I
feel a little nervous and even though I
don't have all the answers I can trust
that I can figure it out and so that's
the kind of biggest picture that I want
you to switch your mind from thinking
you gotta fix this for your kids
and that's us buying into the anxiety
and realize that when anxiety is present
it means that your child my child can't
cope with uncertainty and now as a
parent it's my job to teach them how
when's the last time
you felt excited
because you're up to something that was
either cool or it was new or it was
exciting you know I think about times in
my life when I was up to something
it's like those moments of anticipation
I was applying to college or I was
applying to law school or I was making a
decision that I was going to leave a job
that I didn't like or even after a
breakup you know where you're newly
single and you feel like whoa oh I love
how many of you are saying right now
right now I feel like I'm up to
something
right now you know I feel like I could
be a part of something or maybe for many
of you who are saying I don't feel that
way Mel I'm feeling like my life is
pretty stagnant it was a long time ago I
can't remember when
I want to have you imagine something
imagine
how energizing and exciting it would be
to wake up every day and feel like
you're a part of something really cool
imagine if you made a decision
that starting literally today
you were going to be up to something you
were going to push yourself you know it
makes me kind of sad everybody how many
of you are sitting there saying
um I can't even remember I've lost my
direction and I want to tell you
something
if you feel lost if you feel stuck if
you feel like it has been way too long
since you've had something that you've
looked forward to
I um I want to tell you something
you deserve you deserve to have that
energy back in your life you deserve to
get the push that you need because yet
last night was a reminder of something
you know it's so easy and I I know that
I can fall into this too it's so easy to
kind of get stuck in your rut especially
after working from home for two years
especially after coming through the
pandemic especially after being in this
routine of isolation and feeling like
nothing is ever going to change last
night for me being in New York City and
just coming down and being with friends
and seeing how energizing it is to be
around people that are up to something
it reminded me of this piece of research
that when you hear it it sounds kind of
stupid right but then when you stop and
think about it it's so true
when researchers study happiness you
want to know something crazy about happy
people
happy people
are just prioritizing and making time to
do the little things that make them
happy
and what we also know and you know this
too that when you look forward and you
see things in your calendar just this
weekend for example just this weekend
having something that you've planned
something that you're going to be a part
of that just having something just out
in the near future to look forward to it
gives you two bursts of energy two
number one the planning of it makes you
think about it right and as you
anticipate it and you anticipate what
something is going to be like
you get this burst of energy and then
the doing of it makes you feel energized
and excited again okay and so last night
when I came down here to New York City
to support my friend tune day and be a
part of her big event here in New York
launching her book just thinking about
the fact that it was coming up made me
feel excited and energized and being
there made me feel excited and energized
what is a mindset
well your mindset is your beliefs and
your opinions about the way that the
world works that's the definition when
you look it up however you know that I
prefer metaphors Mel Robbins is dyslexic
so she likes to be able to visualize
something especially when we're talking
about this intellectual stuff okay so
the metaphor that I love when it comes
to mindset and the sciency psychological
neurological aspect of mindset and brain
programming is I use the metaphor
sunglasses
I think about your mindset like a pair
of sunglasses
so stop and think right now about your
favorite pair of sunglasses now I want
you to think about the lens color
and think about how when you put on that
pair of sunglasses
that lens on your favorite sunglasses
it colors and filters what you see
and it gives it a tent right I mean if
you put on rose-colored sunglasses the
world has a Rosy bright tint to it if
you put on Amber sunglasses same thing
gray same thing my big black bug-eyed
glasses that I just love I Feel So
Glamorous in these 15 plastic things
everything looks crazy dark just really
blocks everything out
your mindset works the same way as a
pair of sunglasses
let's go back to the written definition
of your mindset your mindset is made up
of your beliefs and your opinions and
just like the lens on a pair of
sunglasses those beliefs and opinions
that you have they create a mindset
through which you filter the world your
mindset determines the way you view the
world and that determines how you think
so I want to do a gut check right now
with you
if you had to tell the truth
or actually let's make this really
accurate
if your best friend had to describe
the color of the sunglasses that you
wear
would they say that you're more on the
lane of the dark bug eyed plastic
glasses that just skewed everything like
it was midnight
or are you more on the range of
everything's Rosy you're always positive
you are always upbeat you see beauty
where most people see nothing
do a quick gut check with yourself
because your mindset is critical
it shapes the way you view the world and
that determines how and what you think
about it also determines how you feel
about the present moment about your past
and about the future and most
importantly this is where it gets really
important your mindset determines what
actions you take and what actions you
don't take and it also impacts how you
see other people how can I get started
on my dreams and make them a reality
where do I start Mel there's so much
self-doubt it's overwhelming and I just
don't know where to begin once somebody
knows what they want to change or why
they want to change it the next big
question is how and so I'm going to
answer Jessica's question in two parts
because there are two parts to how
the first part is easy it's the doing
part
and how you get started when it comes to
taking action and you don't know what to
quote do
this is easy
just go to Google
I'm I'm dead serious about this
Google has the answer to everything if
you simply go to Google or go to YouTube
and type in the change you want to make
or the goal that you have or the thing
that you want to create in your life you
will probably get 6.3 million search
results and every single one of the
links that you click on will give you a
long list of things that you could
probably do and I'm not being a smart
ass here
the fact is
the steps that you need to take action
wise are super simple
the reason why you're stuck is because
of the second part of her question
now did you notice she said at the very
end
my self-doubt my self-doubt because one
of the reasons why
you get stuck is because of the doubt
and this is where working on your dreams
and your goals gets really tricky
because if your own mindset is working
against you you're actually never going
to feel inspired or motivated or
encouraged to take the actions that that
Google result just told you to take
and so we got to focus on your mindset
first and foremost when it comes to
where do I start
because I want to play this out with you
let's just role play here
if you're sitting there going
I would love to become an opera singer
but I don't know but self-doubt but what
if I sound stupid but this but that but
what if Uncle Willie's if you start
doubting your ability to make that
happen
how motivated do you feel
if you're sitting there telling yourself
that you can't do it or that it's not
going to work
this is the reason why
most people never even get started on
their goals and dreams
their thinking pattern is the problem
because their self-doubt their
perfectionism their lack of self-worth
it's convincing you not to take the
action what is the five second rule it's
a form of metacognition that gives you
immediate control over your thoughts and
actions using the rule is so simple the
moment you feel your instincts fire up
just start counting backwards to
yourself to switch the gears in your
mind
54321 then give yourself a push forward
counting backwards requires focus and
when you focus your prefrontal cortex
awakens and by the way that's the part
of the brain that helps you learn new
positive behavior patterns I first
mentioned the rule and it's Ted Talk
since then more than 8 million people
have discovered the rule through that
talk and its powerful countdown trick to
take control of their lives become more
confident happy and even make their
dreams come true now first let's talk a
little bit about productivity as a
concept productivity is not about
blasting through your to-do list and
doing more it's actually about doing
less productivity is the ability to make
progress in the things that matter to
you
it sounds simple right I mean just move
the ball down the field on the important
stuff but it's not easy why blame your
feelings you see you're capable of being
more productive you're just waiting to
feel like doing what you need to do and
guess what you're never going to crack
the whip on yourself when you have a
million other things that you need to do
and you got people that are making
demands on you
one thing that you must understand is
that you have the power to decide what's
important
and productivity actually boils down to
simple five second decisions
here's one that you need to start making
immediately that will have a tremendous
impact on your ability to be productive
when the alarm goes off
do you wake up early to work on your
business or do you blow it off because
you don't feel like it you're tired or
do you stick to the plan to finish some
important tasks or be a Mainline
Facebook instead because ah you'd just
rather relax when you change your
decisions you'll change everything
because productivity boils down to the
ability to make small five-second
decisions that put the things that are
important first and here's one five
second decision that will make you more
productive than any other get up 30
minutes earlier than you normally do and
push yourself to work on the most
important priorities first
this isn't just me research shows that
your most productive hours are the first
two to three hours after you wake up and
get ready this means that for Peak
productivity you've got to do whatever
you can do to make sure the most
important work to you gets done first
during that window of time so here's how
you're going to use the rule the moment
your alarm goes off and you want to hit
the snooze button use the rule 54321
push yourself out of bed then use the
rule again 54321 sit down and get
working on the things that matter to you
instead of checking your phone instead
of letting your day get hijacked you see
the moment you feel yourself wanting to
give in to distraction you're going to
use the rule again
54321 do a search control and get back
on task to the things that matter to you
it doesn't really matter how busy you
are we're all busy if you really care
you'll find the time and that's how
you're going to use the rule to find the
time to work on things that matter to
you if you feel stuck right now if you
feel like you're in a rut if you just
got dumped or fired or you're going
through a divorce or you put on more
weight than you've ever had or you're
just feeling kind of lost in life you
have no clue what you want to do
here's a tip from your friend Mel
Robbins
if you don't know what to do in that
situation sign up for something
challenging
train for a marathon
commit to doing something that feels
hard as hell and that pushes you outside
of your comfort zone something that
forces you to add something new to your
life like a training run every single
day or a class where you're going to
learn something or a meditation
Challenger hell 75 harder how about this
one if you don't know how to swim and
you're an adult
it'd be pretty confronting to go to your
local Y and sign up for an adult
beginner swim class and learn how to
swim which is a life-saving skill
or maybe you want to sign up for Tango
lessons and you've always thought about
how fun it would be to dance in
competitions see what's interesting
about a challenge of something scary and
hard is it forces you to level up every
area of your life because you won't be
successful adding this challenge into
your life and completing the goal if you
don't change your life and your habits
and the systems of your day-to-day life
in order to be a person who can achieve
this goal it literally shocks you to
your core when you sign up for a
challenge and it reminds you
I'm more powerful than I think I'm not
stuck in this situation or this
relationship or this dead-end job I'm
more powerful than I think and just
trying this online challenge or training
for this Marathon or this you know road
race or this walking thing or whatever
it's getting me back in touch with me
when you allow yourself to Envision the
thing you deeply want the most like I
have the same thing about launching a
podcast I if I really allow myself to
believe it it's that we will be the
number one podcast period And I can feel
it that is my soul pulling me forward
but what's keeping me from really going
all in and doing the work is this deep
sense that I still am not worthy of the
things that I want yep and so the battle
for you is not well for me it's not with
fear it's with this opinion that I don't
deserve to be happy or I don't deserve
and am not worth or not good enough to
have something that magnificent and that
is what holds me back Neuroscience
academic research and other people's
personal experiences can provide
unbelievable insights into how when and
why Behavior change efforts on your part
can succeed or fail
and I want you to have all of this and
be able to use it to your advantage I
already mentioned that 81 percent of
people give up on their goals well guess
what that's not going to be you because
you my friend are going to have the
science the tools the strategies the
shortcuts to not only making change
happen but making it stick and so this
awesome series that we are programming
and bringing to life for you is going to
begin today with the topic of goal
setting because one of the things that I
know based on the research is that no
change will last in your life if it's
not personally connected to you and no
goal will be achieved if you don't have
a connection to why you want to achieve
it and so I figured if we're going to do
a big series that's going to give you
the foundational aspect and most recent
research around changing your life we
better start with an episode where you
identify personal relevant and
achievable goals that you're excited
about that way every single other
episode that you hear in this series for
the next month or so it's going to help
you achieve something that really
matters to you and the fact is goals
matter according to the research and you
probably have experienced this when you
have been working on goals goals matter
because number one they make you happier
number two they suppress negative
emotions and in fact based on some
groundbreaking research out of the
University of Wisconsin having goals
that you're working on can even suppress
feelings of fear and depression and
that's pretty cool
third goals give you a sense of purpose
meaning and being up to something in
fact I just had a conversation with our
daughter Sawyer who was saying that
she's kind of in a rut she's like I just
feel like my life is the same old same
old like every day is the same damn day
and it's only gotten worse because she
works remote and she's worked remote for
over a year and a half since she first
interned for the company she works for
as a senior in college she's almost
never gone into the office no holiday
parties no nothing in person every day
she sits at her desk at home and works
virtually she hangs out with her
roommates so she loves but it's like the
same thing in and out you want to know
what's going to fix this goals
because when you have goals it
interrupts the day-to-day doldrum it
gives you something to look forward to
it makes you feel like something cool is
happening and that leads me to the
fourth benefit life is harder when you
have no goals
based on the research having goals makes
your life feel easier and I think even
just that little story I just told you
about my daughter feeling like she's in
a rut you can see that when you're in a
rut
life is hard
when you feel stuck when things are
monotonous
it's hard
when you got something that excites you
something that you're working toward
that's pretty awesome
and that's why we you and me we are
going to start with your goals because
they matter
and what also matters is how you set
them
because if you don't set goals the right
way
based on science you fail before you
even start and that was Mel Robbins for
years
how you can interrupt negative thoughts
and flip into a positive mindset and why
would you want to do that well the
reason why you want to do that is
because your thoughts Lead You In a
particular direction and if you start to
allow your mind to dwell on negative
outcomes if you start to obsess that
things are not going to work out if you
allow yourself to continue
to think negative thoughts you're not
only priming your mind to default to
negative but you will literally
through your thoughts trigger negative
actions you know if you think about it
you've had experiences in your life
right where you've really trashed
yourself you've hated on yourself and
when you continually think that you hate
yourself or you continually
um tell yourself that you're screwing up
you tend to do things that you hate
don't you but when you're in a positive
mindset when you're in an optimistic
mindset when you interrupt those
negative thoughts and you start to say
well maybe it is going to work out or
you know I gotta just keep on going your
thoughts literally can trigger positive
action too for 25 years I've had a head
full of ideas I've had half-assed
projects and lots of plans I chose
always wishing
overdoing many of my blocks were due to
fear many just basic survival the idea
of goal setting it really fires me up
the idea of remembering to revisit those
goals about freaks man I just think of
all the things that I should have done
and want to do still that I again I've
thought about over the last 25 years
what do you have a vision board for that
seems like what are you a child let me
tell you why vision boards can be
important with one huge caveat based on
science
vision boards are important
because when you take the time to create
a vision board which is basically
bringing your dream or your goal to Life
by creating a collage of images what
you're doing is you are grabbing that
dream or that goal that typically we
bounce around in the back of our minds
in private you're pulling it out of your
mind
and you're grounding it in reality
and one of the reasons why this can be
so powerful is because it signals to
your brain that this is really important
to you we've talked in previous episodes
about the zygarnic effect it creates
this kind of to-do list in your mind the
other reason why it's important is
because when you put a vision board in a
place where you can see it it keeps
these goals and dreams front and center
which is really important but here's the
problem
everybody puts the wrong on their vision
boards you've been sold a bill of goods
you have been told that if you simply
create a collage of some beach house or
your dream body or a million dollars in
the bank or a Maserati that suddenly the
universe is going to hand you those
things that's not how that works
what research shows is exactly what
Rochelle is talking about if all you
ever do is think about the big thing you
think about the end goal the beach house
the Maserati the thing that's like 10
years from now and then you create this
beautiful collage of this amazing thing
that you want that's a huge mistake
and see everybody makes this mistake if
you look at anybody's vision board you
know what's on it it's beach houses and
a million dollars in a Maserati and the
finishing line at the New York City
marathon and all the things that you
hope and dream for and the reason why
that's a huge mistake is that if the
only thing that is on your vision board
is the thing that's going to take you 10
years to get done as you sit here in
your studio apartment
or in the spare bedroom of your parents
house
at a desk in the corner
and you stare at a 10 million dollar
beach house
oh my God
that is going to feel so far away
it's going to feel like
you might as well move to Mars for
crying out loud instead of that vision
board keeping your dreams front and
center that vision board is rubbing them
in your face it's not motivating at all
why because you start to become present
day in and day out to how far away you
are
from that dream of yours
and that starts to make you feel less
motivated it doesn't surprise me at all
that Rochelle has been thinking about
all kinds of things for 25 years and yet
she can't get started
and the reason why is because she is
making the mistake of visualizing the
end I believe that in some way your life
or the last three years
or the uncertainty that you have come
through
or the issues in your life that you have
survived have left the light switch on
your nervous system is in a state of
alert
that annoying light bulb is blinking
in the background
and it's time to turn it off
and so we're going to turn it off using
the vagus nerve
the vagus nerve runs from your seat
all the way through your body through
every major organ through your vocal
cords and all the way up to the top of
your head
and the technical term when you flip the
switch is your quote toning the vagus
nerve that's what researchers and
neuroscientists say I just say let's
just flip the switch let's just use the
vagus nerve and there's lots of ways
that you can do this
so the vagus nerve
when you hum hmm
when you sing I think one of the reasons
why so many of us love singing whether
you're singing in a religious ceremony
or you're singing with friends or you're
singing in the cars you're driving you
don't realize this but in addition just
music's awesome is that when you are
singing you are flipping the switch
on the vagus nerve in your vocal cords
another way you can do this take a warm
bath
just go soak in a tub
it's amazing I love doing that
absolutely love doing that and another
way that you can do this you see this
all over the internet
cold exposure therapy
now I have a tub that I climb into I
hate it absolutely hate it
but this has been transformational
because when you
put yourself in a situation
whether you're jumping into a lake or
you're sitting in a cold bathtub or
whatever standing in a cold shower just
to end your shower with 30 seconds of
cold water it sucks
and what you're doing is you're exposing
your body to a situation where your
nervous system turns on the lights go on
baby when you climb into 34 degree water
and it freaks out and then you calm
yourself down by breathing and you are
training yourself
that even in situations where I get
triggered even in situations that are
awful like 34 degree water that I'm
sitting in I have the power to flip this
switch and calm my ass down
breathe through it and know that I'm
going to be okay
that's a freaking superpower
and I know what you're thinking you're
like
are you showing me Mel Robbins
you're telling me to deal with trauma
by taking a freaking bath
you're telling me that I can handle
abuse from childhood and poverty and all
this crap that I've had to like deal
with my losing my spout and by taking a
cold what is wrong with you woman
yeah I am telling you that because
this is not about the shower this is not
about the bath this is about you and
your nervous system
this is about you training yourself
that you have the power
to be okay
no matter what's going on around you
that you are bigger than the things that
you survived
that yeah by standing in a shower you're
training yourself
for confidence for the capacity to just
to feel something and get triggered and
not let it hijack your life
that's what this is about and when you
do that you take that new you into your
life
you take a person who has the capacity
to have go sideways in your life
and not get hijacked by it
you become the kind of person that could
have survived horrendous trauma
and be able to
heal yourself over time close your eyes
and think about the next year of your
life
what do you want the next year of your
life to look like
Begin by making a wish
that's how I began two years ago
yep my business was upside down kids
were in shambles my husband was
struggling with depression and I was
struggling with everything
I had to create a break from that moment
of pain
and allow myself to see something
different at the time I had no idea what
the new chapter of my life would be or
could be here's what I did know I want
to stay in this one and that's all you
need to know
all you need to know is you don't want
to stay in the place that you're in
right now
that right there is a wish for something
better if you know what you don't want
it's very easy to change as soon as you
start removing or letting go of things
that aren't working you'll see all new
possibilities no matter how you feel
start taking the actions that align with
what you want in your life
stop making the mistake of waiting to
feel happy or motivated before you take
action the secret it's taking action
first because if you can get moving you
can keep moving and research shows that
just a little boost in your mood impacts
your productivity for the rest of the
day it impacts your focus it gives you a
little uptick in energy taking actions
that align with the bigger vision and
the future you it Taps into this huge
body of research called behavioral
activation therapy now you're going to
learn a tremendous amount about this
therapy modality in future episodes of
the Mel Robbins podcast but here's how
I'd summarize it for you act like the
person you want to become in the future
no matter how you feel in the present
moment look I know it sounds simple act
like the future you but this is grounded
in decades of research and it works this
is how I've made every single change in
my life once I figure out what I want to
do or the kind of person I want to
become I figure out someone else in the
world that's doing it and I just reverse
engineer it and that's how you create a
brick path that leads from where you are
right now to where that wish of yours
wants to take you and every morning wake
up take one action in the lines with
what you want or the person that you
want to become and you can consider that
action it represents one brick
and if you keep doing that day by day
Brick by Brick action by action you're
going to look up a year from now and
you'll realize oh my God I just paved a
brick path leading to my dreams you are
in control
of the one thing that everybody cares
about that everybody complains about and
everybody's trying to steal from you and
that is your time and in fact if you're
worried about not having enough time let
me tell you something that I know about
you you're not using your time
effectively you're not being deliberate
about how you're spending your time and
the problem isn't time and whether or
not you have enough of it the problem is
you're not being completely selfish
deliberate and
just in control of how you're spending
it you're letting other people distract
you you're letting your negative beliefs
distract you and so that's got to stop
today because here's the truth whether
you're 70
or you're 77. you have plenty of time to
start working toward the things that you
care about one of the things that I wear
right now is my little my intent
bracelet this little thing and my word
for the year is deliberate
and when it comes to time you have to be
deliberate because you have plenty of
time it's a matter of whether or not
you're being deliberate about how you're
using it and that's the thing that you
have to stop you got to stop giving your
time away you got to stop wasting your
time with people you don't care about
you got to stop wasting time listening
to this the excuses from the past they
don't apply you can make anything happen
if you just start putting in the work
and that's going to require you to get
deliberate about making the time to do
the work and you can do the work that
you need to do to change your life 10
minutes a day that's it start working 10
minutes a day start taking an online
course start investigating going back to
school start following people that
inspire you around launching your own
business you have time so stop with the
habit of telling yourself you don't the
only advice that's going to work is vice
is advice is that you Flex to work in
your life
and so one of the reasons why I'm
constantly sharing these really simple
things to do is because that's the only
things that I can fit into my life my
life is very complicated just like yours
and so I can't fit in two hours of
exercise
but I can fit in 15 minutes
I can't fit in training for a marathon
right now but I can get a walk in three
days a week
and so what you're going to find is that
if you hold yourself to an impossible
standard you're going to feel like that
standard is impossible
if you become not only realistic about
the demands of your life
but you also become very rigorous about
what you demand of yourself in terms of
you know I'm not going to force myself
to some ridiculous standard I got two
toddlers I'm a single parent it's not
safe for me to walk alone outside and
leave them I just can't do it so what
can I do
and so
when you say so that's so that's just
hopefully getting rid of like the
the kind of
comparison thing because I do it too you
know I often have this conversation with
Christine who's our chief operating
officer of 143 Studios which is our
production company and she's also my
sister-in-law and I love her because I'm
like the flighty creative ball dropper
genius type person right I call myself a
genius like ingest but I'm creatively
fruity all over the place just flying
high she is a CFO Excel spreadsheet get
everything in the columns kind of lady
Mel says yes Christine says no that's
basically the joke inside the company
Mel said yes but Christine said no so
anyway I was complaining to her the
other day because
um of course like you I bash myself when
I see other people out achieving me
because I've got to win some imaginary
competition here in life and I see a
friend of mine who is going on a book
tour
and he is going on a book tour that is
lasting three months
and I turned to Christine I'm like this
is unbelievable it's so cool
and she turned me and she goes
he doesn't have children
you can't be on the road that long Mel
it's not gonna work for you
and I'm like oh
that's right she's like you gotta stop
comparing yourself to people whose lives
don't look like yours
you will never be able to achieve
what somebody who is a single male can
achieve because you've got other demands
on your time right now you will never be
able to achieve what a 23 year old can
do right now because you've got aging
parents and three kids and a business to
run and so please please stop making
yourself feel like
because you are looking at somebody who
has totally different life circumstances
than you and by the way this does not
mean that there's something wrong with a
23 year old Fitness influencer I think
that's freaking fantastic that
somebody's doing that with their life
there's nothing wrong with somebody who
is going on a book tour for three months
I think that's fantastic and there's
clearly a part of me that wants to do
more of that but at the moment
I gotta face reality and the reality is
based on my values based on what life
looks like right now
I'm not going to do that but what I can
do is figure out what advice I respond
to what changes I want to make and then
I can fit that into my life in making
powerful change in your life
find the proof that you can do it
it's all around you you just need to
look for it
find anyone that has the life that you
want or that has made the change that
you want to make the relationship the
career the body the family the friend
group anytime you see someone who has
already made the change you want to make
in your life tell yourself there's proof
it exists use people as evidence that
yes you can have what you wish for too
if you're willing to work for it see
people as a light on the path to your
future self for years that was not me I
was the opposite I did not see other
people as lights on my path I saw people
as Robin me of the lights that I wanted
I had this really stingy jealous and
insecure attitude if a friend of mine
was renovating their kitchen I would
smile the tight smile that people have
when they're faking their smile and I go
oh it's so pretty I love the white
cabinets but inside I was seething with
jealousy and the reason why is because I
believed that somebody else's happiness
or success somehow was robbing me of
mine it's the opposite their beautiful
kitchen means if I can work for it I can
have one too they're amazing
relationships means I can create it too
their success or the business they've
built means it's possible for you too
this alone if you just do this third
step this one mindset flip it is a
complete Game Changer here's how you do
it there is unlimited success happiness
and fulfillment in the world
you're not in competition with anyone
the only one that can rob you of the
success happiness and fulfillment that
you deserve is you and your excuses and
fears and sitting around waiting to feel
motivated we're going to stop that today
correct good I'm glad you're listening
because we're not doing that anymore
you're not going to wait six years to
get started you are going to start
taking actions that align with what you
want now and when you see other people
as evidence of what's possible for you
as you start seeing them not as
extinguishing your light
but lighting the path that you're now
walking on holy cow talk about throwing
gasoline on that internal fire of yours
and by the way
don't you ever forget
you are a light on the path for someone
else and you don't even realize it
so
think about that for a second
you are just a step or two ahead of
someone else
I mean if you've grieved the loss of a
loved one if you've changed your career
if you've survived heartache if you've
sold a family home if you've reinvented
some aspect of your life if you've lost
weight if you're able to live with
depression if you were the first in your
family to graduate from college your
life experience proves to someone else
that it's possible for them too
so you better make sure that as you
start chipping away at your own wishes
and goals that you hold that light up a
little bit higher for everybody that's
behind you when you have a limiting
belief
so that default Network in your mind is
programmed to think you're not enough or
the default Network in your mind is
programmed to think it never works out
for me or the default Network in your
mind is programmed to say
I'm never going to make it
what happens with a limiting belief is
that you actively because of the default
Network in your brain is your brain is
actively filtering in and out
information
that agrees with the limiting belief and
so your whole mind is set up to view the
world and look for evidence that you're
not enough that things aren't working
out that you're never going to make it
so there's a big difference between the
reality
that you're food compromised the reality
that you're unemployed the reality that
you're living with depression the
reality that you're divorced the reality
that uh you dropped out of school and
you want to go back and now study to
become a nurse those are harsh or can be
harsh realities it can be liberating
realities for some people not everybody
of course because those are very very
real and tough circumstances okay to be
food deprived I don't mean to say that
that's a liberating circumstance I meant
it from the dropping out going back to
school so let me be clear very harsh
reality to be food compromised very
harsh reality to be unemployed very
harsh reality to live with depression
very harsh reality to get dumped very
harsh reality to have a diagnosis that's
terrifying get it I totally get it
that is very different
than having the harsh reality be your
brain
and you've got a terrible diagnosis and
all your brain is doing is saying I'm
gonna die I'm never gonna survive this
my chances are
you got it so that you're making it
worse because of your default settings
um I want to train you regardless of the
harsh circumstances that you're living
in
that you get to choose how you view the
circumstances you get to choose how you
view the future you get to choose
whether or not you see nothing but
problems nothing but excuses nothing but
reasons to be depressed and sad and to
check out or whether you can train
yourself to still have hope to still get
up and try to still get up and be
positive to still get up and look for
opportunities to make your life just a
little bit better that's the difference
between harsh realities and your
limiting beliefs harsh realities are
temporary
you can change them
limiting beliefs will keep you stuck in
a permanent mental state because you are
continuing to look for evidence to make
negative beliefs true and that's why we
want to turn you into a deliberate
thinker and one of the reasons why it's
so important for you to be clear about
what you want out of this next chapter
in your life is because who you hang out
with
it changes everything for you it either
keeps things the same
or it will be an accelerant that makes
it easier for you to make the changes in
your life that you really want to make
and so this is research from Harvard
that I want you to understand and it's
what is grounding the advice that I'm
giving you today
so do you know that when researchers
from Harvard looked at people who had
made a major change in their lives in a
positive way okay so you take a group of
people that made a major change in their
life
half of those people the reason why that
change happened is because something
either traumatic
or something that was a major life event
happened they got cancer they lost
somebody they loved they got a divorce
they suddenly were laid off they lost
all their money like something happened
that was a major life event that rocked
them and you know what happens when that
happens to you first it's horrendous but
it usually leads to something very
positive happening now the other half of
the people who had made a very positive
change in their life do you want to know
what they did what they did is they
changed their friends
they started surrounding themselves with
people that were up to the same thing
that they wanted to be doing I'm sure
you've experienced this in your life
have you ever
um gone to college and when you get to
college and suddenly you're around a
bunch of studious people it suddenly
makes you more studious have you ever
done a 5k or run a half marathon or done
a big walking uh fundraiser or done
tough mud or one of those big kind of
group events what's it like to be at a
race where people are cheering you on
where other people are running where
you're all doing the same thing it's
super motivating and there's even deeper
research around this because behavior is
contagious
if you're around people that smoke your
objection to smoking gets lowered
because you get socialized to it if
you're around people that are super
positive your natural set in terms of
being pessimistic will slowly start to
raise if you're around people that every
morning they send a text I've got two
friends hi Jenny hi Sarah two of my uh
friends here that I text almost every
other day about what exercise class
we're going to just being around them
makes me more motivated and so James and
you I want you to really understand that
who you hang out with matters it matters
not only because your time is valuable
and your attention is valuable and your
heart and soul is valuable but it
matters because the people that you hang
out with have an incredible impact on
you I believe that you are capable of
changing I do I've just seen too much
evidence over the course of my career
amazing changes the people just like you
and me have made so I know you're
thinking well this is great Mel but
where do I begin so step number one
You Begin by making a wish
just like that moment on your birthday
when you close your eyes and wish for
something to come true in this next year
of your life
right now do the same
close your eyes
and think about the next year of your
life
what do you want the next year of your
life to look like
Begin by making a wish
that's how I began two years ago
yep my business was upside down kids
were in shambles my husband was
struggling with depression and I was
struggling with everything
I had to create a break from that moment
of pain
and allow myself to see something
different at the time
I had no idea what the new chapter of my
life would be or could be here's what I
did know I want to stay in this one and
that's all you need to know
all you need to know is you don't want
to stay in the place that you're in
right now
that right there is a wish for something
better if you know what you don't want
it's very easy to change as soon as you
start removing or letting go of things
that aren't working you'll see all new
possibilities true confidence Begins the
moment you're willing to try
okay and so I I really think it's
important I can give you another example
the first time somebody handed me
chopsticks I had no idea how to use them
was I nervous about
picking them up and I couldn't get like
my fingers to twist in the way that
you're supposed to and it was super
embarrassed and they kept like flipping
across the table and everybody
here's the thing I didn't know how to
use them
but isn't it common sense that there's
no way I was going to learn how to use
them if I wasn't willing to try
see being confident and the skill of
confidence is the difference between
saying sure hand me the Chopsticks I'd
love to try I'm willing to look like an
idiot I'm willing to be a beginner first
versus going can you get me a fork I
don't know how to use those
do you see the difference
the skill begins with being willing to
try so many of you saw me on the Today
Show today
that is the culmination of 10 years of
being willing to try being willing to
walk on a stage and have a panic attack
or a neck rash being willing to get
behind a microphone and make terrible
content or say stupid things or look
terrible in videos you know you got to
remember what you're seeing is a person
on the Today Show who has been working
hard for 10 years trying over and over
and over and over and learning and
failing that's what you're witnessing
you're witnessing competency but the
skill is something different the skill
of confidence is trying and you know let
me remind you of a fact everybody starts
at zero everyone
whether you're trying to learn guitar
or you're building a social media
following or you want to get into the
YouTube space or you're writing a book
or you're selling out everybody starts
at zero that's how I started zero
speeches given zero television
experience zero social media following
zero email addresses zero competency in
front of a camera or on a microphone I
mean even take this podcast starting
this I started at zero the tech is
intimidating there are five million
podcasts on Spotify alone I'm 54 years
old I don't know how to do that I
haven't done this before I haven't been
in the seat of the person that hosts but
here's the difference with your friend
Mel Robbins I'm willing to try
I lean on this skill of confidence that
I've built because I have the definition
that's grounded in research and so do
you
you're not going to feel confident
you're going to act
in accordance with the research of
confidence you my friend are willing to
try
that's the secret the businesses that
were launched by somebody like you who
was working full-time while launching
your business had a 33 percent less
chance of failing
than the people that quit their jobs and
jump all in
and the reason why is you know how to
hedge your bets you're a little
conservative in terms of the risks that
you'll take which means over the long
term your business is more likely to
succeed you asked me how do I balance my
passions how do you find the time
because I like you have a million things
going on from being an on-air
commentator to CNN to having an
incredible partnership with Success
magazine and doing a ton of cool stuff
with them to giving over 80 speeches a
year and running a company and having a
family
the key is this you must find 30 minutes
before 7 30 in the morning 30 minutes
before 7 30. that you take at home that
you take at a coffee shop where you
organize your day and you work on two
things that will push your business
forward
30 minutes before 7 30. why do you need
to do this well because when you walk
into work your day is likely going to
get hijacked and secondly if you were to
take this time every single morning and
focus yourself you're now starting your
day having already done work to advance
your business and you're walking into
your current job knowing what you need
to get done that's going to make you
work smarter at work I think a lot of
people that are working a job full-time
and also trying to launch a business on
the side actually have the time the
problem is that you're not being
rigorous and focused about what you're
spending it on what you're dealing with
when you have imposter syndrome is
you're dealing with a lack of self-worth
you literally
kind of see all the things working out
but you've got this like annoying voice
in your head that's saying you don't
deserve this this is luck how many of
you have that story this is locked this
is going to run out this isn't due to me
yeah we got to literally destroy that
voice that is from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
boy that voice by the way is because of
racism it's because of discrimination
it's because of childhood trauma it's
because of uh various experiences that
you've had where either your experiences
growing up or Society at large has made
you feel either overtly or in a really
like gross and sort of Sly way like you
don't belong and so it is critical for
you to start to punch that voice
literally out of your head and I'm going
to give you some steps to do it okay
the second thing that's really important
is that in addition to stopping down
that voice because it's not your voice
that is somebody else's voice that your
brain listened to
and then started repeating
and the thing about your brain is that
your brain is this really cool computer
that learns patterns
and what I want you to understand is
that patterns repeat
unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has
that says you're not worthy you don't
deserve this luck is going to run out at
some point that you know what's going to
hit the fan again
brace
don't count on anything
like you didn't earn this if you got
that pattern running in your head that
is a broken pattern
you're not broken
that pattern of thinking is broken
and so the Line in the Sand that I want
to draw starting today is you're not
allowed to listen to that garbage
anymore
we are going to go on a mission together
to notice whenever it comes up oh
interesting there it is there's that
pattern it's spinning just like a load
of laundry right up there and I'm going
to teach you once you recognize that
pattern you're going to use this thing
that I created called the five second
rule you're going to count backwards
five four three two one because that
shuts that down
and counting backwards let's all do it
together here we go five four three two
one now notice when you counted did you
feel a little pressure right here
yeah that was me hypnotizing you no I'm
just kidding
um
what you were feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain hack that interrupts all the
garbage that's here in the interior part
of your brain this is where imposter
syndrome lives everybody this is where
anxiety is this is where self-doubt is
this is where self-criticism is this is
where it's all stored when you notice oh
there's that voice again and you count
backwards five four three two one you
shut it down
and then you awaken this part of your
brain this is the part of the brain that
you used when you were taking the SATs
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you applied for that job when
you speak up in that meeting when you
tell somebody no you cannot borrow my
dress tonight no when you have
boundaries right this is the part of the
brain that gives you immediate control
over what you think and do next
and so that's a really important thing
number one you're going to notice it
number two
you're going to name it
so let's give that jerk in your brain a
name so Heidi what do you want to name
this thing
um like close your eyes and think about
it everybody close your eyes and think
about like that voice that nasty stinky
awful skanky gross voice in your head I
want to kind of get an image in your
mind it could be a cartoon character it
could be a human being it could be like
some little pimply
ugly person from middle school that you
feel sorry for now
okay yeah because when you laugh at the
voice it doesn't have control over you
like it did right we want to make this
less serious so what's the name you're
going to give your voice well I was
thinking the voice but maybe something
like I don't know Rocky spiky spiky okay
what name do you want to give your voice
Linda Bob Bob okay how do you say your
name
sadanya great name what are you gonna
give your voice
Maybe Peabody Peabody I got it I got it
okay how about you what's your voice
Bill Bill oh conviction there's a human
being like that talking to you Bill we
are going to shut bill down okay what
about Isabella broccoli broccoli she
hates broccoli I love that that's great
how about you
Josh Josh okay great so whenever you
hear that voice what I'm teaching you is
to use the science of objectivity
to distance yourself from that voice
okay this is so important because you
are not that voice welcome in everybody
actually pull up your chairs closer Do
not sit that far away from me come on
yep let's go you're not late you are
right on time let's welcome them in okay
yep ladder clap ladder
um super important everybody in life to
make people feel welcome
super important to invite people
especially other women
to have a seat at the table
and one of the things that I've learned
and then I'm going to catch you all up
on where we're at okay
one of the things I've learned is that
you know it's there's so much success to
go around
have you wrapped your brain around the
fact that there are what eight billion
people on this planet
there is so much success to go around
there's so much happiness
there's a tremendous amount of money to
make
there's a ton of people to date
and when you
focus on the fact that there is
Limitless possibilities for you
you're not in competition with anybody
in this room
and the louder you cheer for other
people
the more you invite people in
the more you will be invited in and the
more cheering there will be for you
it is incredible when you can flip your
mind from being jealous and competitive
and small-minded like if she's getting
that it means I don't oh no no no no no
if you see somebody getting something
that you want it's evidence that you can
have it too
you're just going to get it and have it
in your own way
and so you want to make it a habit to
cheer for and celebrate all the all the
women everybody you see around you
because their success means you can have
it too and trust me if you are a
talented hard-working kind person
a company will make room for you
they will find another job doing that
same thing
and so you focus on you you focus on
being the best you and I promise you all
the other people around you that are
having those things that you want
that's evidence you can have it too I
like to think of other people as a light
on the path I'm walking down
they're shining a light that helps me
walk in the direction of what I want
Angie why is it so easy to fill out
limiting beliefs but almost paralyzing
to figure out an alternative think this
not that how many of you are having
trouble with this it's very easy to see
where you doubt yourself but it's super
hard to come up with the alternative
thought that you're going to substitute
well the reason why it's hard is because
you actually believe these thoughts
and these thoughts have become patterns
and they've become habits and they've
become so uh prevalent in your life that
they're almost like the co-host
of your life
um you know if you think about it you
are the star of your life but if the
supporting actor is a limiting belief
that constantly tells you that you're
not good enough or that you're not
worthy or that you'll never succeed then
it's no wonder that you believe it
because the co-star of your life is your
limiting beliefs and so it's not
easy
to change your limiting beliefs but it
is simple
and it begins with you identifying them
and then substituting them so the most I
think effective way of beginning the
process of teaching yourself how to
identify a limiting belief and then come
up with your own
substitute positive belief as a way to
change the negative pattern in your mind
is to use the power of objectivity
so write down all your limiting beliefs
and I'm going to go through this in
detail in just a second write down all
your learning beliefs I'm not worthy I'm
not good enough nothing works out for me
nobody's gonna love me whatever the [__]
it is that you think that's that's
bringing you down and then you can ask
yourself this what would Mel say
if Mel were sitting here across from me
what would Mel say
another thing you can do you can write
the opposite of what you're thinking
and you may not believe it it's okay
because what we're doing is training you
in a new pattern and one of the things
that Angie asked is she wanted to know
what were my limiting beliefs so
yesterday we sent out this workbook the
best decade ever toolkit it's in your
email if you go to the Facebook group
best decade ever with Mel Robbins it's
also listed on the files you'll find the
download for this check your junk email
if you didn't get it but
um so my limiting beliefs
so I want to have the number one talk
show of the decade
and the number one talk show of the
decade right now seems to be Ellen and
so it's interesting because a lot of my
limiting beliefs I think are provoked by
the fact that I'm the newcomer in a
space that I have huge dreams of making
a market and dominating so one of my
limiting belief is someone's already
done it how many of you have that one my
dream has already been done
so my substitute thought because this
feels kind of true doesn't it
somebody's already done it
and then my
substitute thought the Think This Not
That is well they haven't done it my way
yet
it hasn't been done by me yet
do you see what I mean so somebody else
has done it okay I get it it hasn't been
done by me yet
it's it'll never happen
it'll never happen how many of you have
that limiting belief it'll never happen
my substitute belief it hasn't happened
yet
so I'm acknowledging that it hasn't
happened but I'm adding on the yet
as a way to keep my mind in the positive
uh it didn't happen last time so it's
not going to happen this time
how many of you have that one
yep this is what I say I wasn't ready
then
I'm ready now
you know because it didn't happen last
time because I didn't know everything I
know now I'm ready now
uh I don't deserve it how many of you
have this limiting belief I don't
deserve it
my thought is if I work hard I'll earn
it
do you see that so it flips from a
statement where I'm bashing myself worth
I don't deserve it to a statement about
putting in the effort if I work hard
I'll earn it
oh I've got this story that I'm the Bad
News Bears that I'm literally like the
person with the worst equipment and I'm
the underdog and I'm underfunded and
why does it have to be so hard and why
does it seem so much easier for
everybody else blah blah blah blah blah
blah and I flip that into I love being
underestimated and I love being the
undergo
in a very weird way as much as it
exhausts me it also empowers me
um oh here's here's a specific limiting
belief
I'm gonna compete with that
with Alan
um
especially when she's been at it for 20
years she has the budget of God and uh
an army of people that are supporting
her I mean there was something she did
announced yesterday on social media that
I was so like oh of course and I was so
jealous she announced a partnership with
Starbucks where she's encouraging people
to pay for somebody's coffee using the
Starbucks app behind them in line
um and then take a video of it and
upload it they're gonna bring him on the
show and I was like oh will I ever get
there will I ever get the cool stuff
like that and the answer is yeah
she proves it's possible
and also I can take the 10 years and be
like and in 20 years
I won't even recognize the cool stuff
I'll be able to doing if I put in the
work
so take that jealousy or somebody else
or whatever and say it proves it's
possible now put in the work
um so those are some of my limiting
beliefs and that's how you can do it and
by the way if you can't do that exercise
successfully on your own Post in the
Facebook group and tell people this is
your limiting belief can somebody help
you come up with a substitute positive
belief so that you can think this not
that ask somebody in your life to help
you
um and then what you do is when you find
yourself going down the route of that
negative thought it'll never happen
you're gonna five four three two one use
the five second rule to interrupt the
negative belief and then you are going
to insert the positive belief it hasn't
happened yet that's it adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up when the alarm rings
I make my bed I pull on my exercise
clothes I set an intention I high five
myself in the mirror I then go out into
the kitchen I crack open my high five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42 percent more likely
to achieve those goals simply by writing
them down that's pretty cool secondly
your mind is paying attention and when
you take deliberate action and you write
down what you want you are signaling to
your brain that you deserve to have
these things you're signaling to your
brain that you do want those things
you're not just going to think about
them these are things that matter to you
and that helps train your mind to allow
you to let the desires flow through you
because right now you're not manifesting
properly because you're not even
allowing yourself to dream with the lid
off so that's step number one you're
going to start writing down five things
that you want every single morning as a
way to train your mind to let you dream
freely your excuses are [__]
that's right
all those excuses you got
they're just fear
they are just fear
when you learn the lesson when you turn
toward the friction in your life and you
look for either the process or the
people or the place that you're living
or the place that you work
all of the things the thinking patterns
that you have the behavior patterns when
you start to identify everybody all of
the areas of friction in your life
and you go to work to learn the lesson
here's what I want you to know you are
capable of changing it
you are 100 capable of learning the
lesson and making anything in your life
better
I know that is true about you and that
means that the only thing that is
keeping you
from identifying the things that aren't
working and doing the work to move your
life into alignment with who you're
meant to be and the things that truly
make you come alive the only thing
that's preventing you from doing that is
you and your fears whether you're like
any excuse that you have is just fear
you're afraid to try you're afraid to
fail you're afraid you're too late
you're afraid of this you're afraid of
that now's not the right time I don't
have this I don't have that this person
would be upset with me all of it is fear
fear of rejection fear of it not working
out fear of disobeying being
disappointed fear of disappointing
others that's what an excuse is you're
just managing fear and it's all baloney
every single time you're procrastinating
it's being triggered by stress
see that's the crazy thing about
procrastination it has nothing to do
with what you need to do
procrastination defined in the
dictionary is avoiding or putting
something off delaying it but when you
look at the research and we're going to
dig into that in a minute the way that
researchers Define procrastination is
that you are avoiding
stress
that's what you're avoiding you're not
avoiding the application you're not
avoiding the illustration
you blow off things that take brain
power because you are trying to avoid
stress procrastination is the attempt to
feel better in this moment
and strangely what you're about to learn
is that when I walk you through this
three-step research-backed technique
that you're going to use every single
time that you catch yourself
procrastinating is that procrastination
is triggered by stress
that's what it's about
I'm going to say that again
procrastination is a habit that you have
learned
and that you repeat whenever you feel
stressed and this comes from research
from Dr Timothy pikel at Carleton
University his definition of
procrastination is this a subconscious
desire to feel good right now
and he shares that procrastination it's
just all about stress and I'm gonna
unpack this for you because when you
first hear that wait procrastination is
a subconscious desire to feel good right
now how the heck does that make sense I
mean vidi really wants to draw Mel
so wouldn't it make sense that she'd
feel good if she were drawing
sort of
and I'm going to explain this it makes
sense intellectually but when I unpack
how stress is triggering you to stop
doing something that you care about or
that you need to do this is all going to
be like holy cow why didn't I hear this
sooner
so I'm going to give you an example
but I want you to understand that that
stress that is triggering you to
procrastinate it could be something
going on in your life right now or it
could be deep seated stress like
childhood trauma it could be anxiety or
depression or something in your past
that you haven't dealt with a situation
that you're worried about that's
completely unrelated to work or to the
things that you need to do it might just
be the Relentless pressure and stress
that you feel because you are so hard on
yourself we spend so much time twisting
ourselves in knots
about unimportant things
and we just talked about how hideous
I'll use the word hideous because I
literally looked hideous I mean I not
only had a tomato red face and like
crazy witch hair and uh foggy glasses
and bad breath and impacted sinuses and
probably throwing in a camel toe in
there too I didn't have anything tied
around my waist
um
but not giving a [__] about that
is very liberating because otherwise I'd
be embarrassed by my own existence
walking down the sidewalk and I would
twist myself in knots worrying about
what do I look like and how right is my
face is my face coming down and maybe I
should go back to the hotel and take a
shower and get this makeup off my face
and blow my nose before I get a cup of
coffee and and all of that energy
twisting myself around what other people
may be thinking rather than just being
okay not giving a [__]
it's so liberating why is it so hard to
break through some daily habits and do
things differently why can't I stay
consistent in my daily tasks I'll tell
you why you're frustrated
the same reason why every any organizer
is frustrated because you are trying to
stay consistent in your head and you are
not using simple systems and simple
physical cues to keep you organized and
to keep these changes top of mind that's
it and you are you are managing so much
and you listening to me you don't give
yourself enough credit for how much
you're juggling in your own mind
stop keeping Behavior change in your own
mind and let's get it out of your head
because I want you to know something
you're not the problem
you have everything within you
you're not the problem you are capable
of learning new habits you are capable
of making amazing things happen you're
not the problem
the problem is that you're attacking
this as an any organizer
you are planning to do this all in your
head
and all you need is Audi systems that
keep these new changes front and center
in front of you that's how you stay
consistent stop relying on Willpower
stop relying on having to remember what
you need to do absolutely not there is
no way you are going to achieve your
goals or stay consistent or make all
those amazing changes that you want to
make that you deserve to have happen
unless you start to implement systems in
your life just to give you a visual
everybody you know tomatoes in high
summer August at a farmer's market
bright deep opaque shiny red that was
basically the color of my face my hair
is starting to grow out so the roots are
coming in nice and gray and I put on my
glasses and they fogged up for all I
know I had a camel toe and I was walking
down uh the sidewalk in La outside of
the yoga studio headed to my favorite
coffee shop to basically get a couple
liquid caffeinated sugar and I pulled
out that phone because I thought you
know what I did not want to go this
morning my sinuses are bothering me I
know you can relate to that and so I
just start filming and I agree I looked
like absolute but here's what I think
I walk around looking like that
so why would I be worried about putting
it online
like if you walk into the grocery store
wearing a pair of yoga
tights and your bra is showing through
your T-shirt and you're sweaty and your
hair is a mess why do you feel bad
putting a photo of yourself looking like
that online
like you got to stop and consider that
you're okay going out in public or being
around friends looking like crap because
that's how we all look in real life but
somehow that's not acceptable
on social media
and so it's been very liberating for me
to just go fit I don't care what I look
like because I walk into a grocery store
looking like this I know I look like who
cares but the public and what I look
like in public is exactly what I'm
willing and I think you should put on
social media because if you don't you're
subconsciously giving us about your
appearance
and I think that's really as you guys
keep like teaming up these examples of
where I'm either completely violating
social norms like the no toes policy
which I was unaware of or I am being
really offensive by taking my shirt off
and doing what I thought was a very
polite discreet move of covering my
nipples with my t-shirt so I could get
some sun because I feel depressed and
translucent like a gray dolphin living
here in southern Vermont but I think the
real liberating thing about learning how
to give a [__] is that you put your
energy toward giving towards things that
matter and you spend less time draining
your energy on this that really doesn't
matter and one of the things that I gave
up a long time ago Christine
is worrying about what I looked like and
maybe it was because of the experience
of being a commentator on CNN because
when I was on CNN I was on CNN as you
know Christine as an on-air commentator
a paid legal commentator there were only
five of us in the entire world that were
on that team and it was a really cool
job analyzing some of the biggest cases
of our time
uh
I noticed something that whenever I
would be on TV and I would have an
opinion about particularly a case that
people were really hot about like um
Trayvon Martin's murder or what happened
in Ferguson or Freddie gray or Tamir
rice and I'm a criminal defense attorney
and so I am adding in commentary as a
defense attorney I notice that when
people criticized me
they never criticized what I said
people on Twitter or on social media
here I am on television talking about a
very serious topic I take the job very
seriously they're like yo bag you know
have you seen your neck you know so who
do like just dragging my down my jowls
that look like saddle bags or my saggy
ass turkey gizzard neck or just
constantly trashing me
that I just learned how to tune it out
and I started to not care and there's
something very liberating about leaving
an exercise class and your mascara from
last night is running down your face
like Dracula and going and getting your
coffee anyway
you know why because you don't give a
[__] what the other people who are
standing in line around you think about
the fact that your mascara is running
and half of them you're probably never
going to see again anyway so who gives a
[__] first we're going to talk about
globally how I want you to think about
being able to focus your attention
and get things done okay and this was on
a day-to-day basis
first of all when I talk about
productivity and the ability to focus
your attention on a day-to-day basis
I want you to understand a simple fact
in order to get things done in order to
direct your focus and move through a
task
you are going to require some brain
power and so I want you to think about
your brain like a car engine right and a
car engine is what you need in a car to
power you forward and your brain is like
an engine that will power you forward to
help you get tasks done now an engine
requires fuel right and sure enough your
brain has a certain amount of fuel so
imagine that you got like a tank that
has fuel in it in your brain okay and as
you wake up and as you go through your
day and as you direct your attention on
things guess what happens to that fuel
in your brain it starts to drain
and so I want you to know this because
the
tactics and the tools that I'm about to
teach you relate to the fuel in your
brain and what times of day you have the
most fuel what times of day you are more
likely to be able to focus okay and what
do you think everybody is the best time
of day for your brain and for the amount
of fuel that you have in your brain
naturally in order to be able to tap
into it and drive your focus at
something that's important to you I love
this you guys are right Laura says my
brain is mushed by the end of the day
everybody's saying morning morning I see
somebody saying I feel like I'm on empty
this is a really good analogy because
there are times where you feel like your
brain is full of gas and you're able to
direct your attention and focus and then
there times you're like Jesus I feel
like I'm running on empty I'm running on
fumes here and you're absolutely right
everybody
it is mornings when you wake up
generally what the research shows is
that your brain is primed to be able to
focus
for the first four hours of the day the
first four hours of the day tend to be
for most of us
the time of day when your brain has the
most fuel and when your speed of
processing is awesome and when you are
able to direct your attention at what
you need to be focused on okay so now
there's a caveat to this
you can manufacture boosts of
productivity and boosts of feeling like
you've got a little bit more brain power
number one immediately after you
exercise so if you have a burst of
cardio 30 minutes is what a lot of the
research says but if you have a burst of
cardio you will get a little bit of
increase in fuel another thing that
helps is getting outside getting outside
uh when you start to feel your energy
and your focus start to go to empty
getting outside is another way to give
yourself a boost of brain power Deborah
says what about complaining about things
that genuinely take time to resolve
like I'm getting over being sick
let me ask you a question
does complaining about being sick
actually help you get better
it's a fair question
you're allowed to complain if it's
productive
if it makes you feel better to go
and saying it is helpful
terrific
if doing that makes you feel even worse
try not to do it
say things like boy I'm on day three of
this I must be getting better
boy uh the meds are going to kick in at
any moment
you know when it starts Chris is looking
at me like what are you talking about no
it's just somebody mentioned do thoughts
count yes outbound sort of out outward
complaining but yeah complaining in your
own mind of course thoughts count
because you know what you complain about
the most
yourself
your body
your intelligence
what you just said
the fact that you didn't go to the gym
the fact that you didn't uh do what you
said you were going to do the beating
yourself up is a form of complaining
because you're expressing
dissatisfaction
for yourself
and the problem with all this is that
when you do it habitually
or when you complain as just a default
mode and you don't realize how much
you're doing it you're allowing your
mind to filter the world a certain way
and you're allowing yourself to live in
existence where your own thoughts are
poisonous
if you feel like hell and you got the
flu and you've just thrown up in the
toilet complain all you want vent all
you want you just earned that but at
some point you're gonna have to stop
feeding the monster and putting poison
in your own mind and you're gonna have
to teach yourself how to start to find
Milestones that are positive
so that you can become healthier so that
you can change how you think if you
struggle with being kind to yourself
it is never too early or too late to
have an enormous breakthrough in your
relationship to yourself
and this is really important it's really
important because based on the research
there was this massive study done in the
UK where they took a look at absolutely
every single Behavior or attitude change
you could make or you could practice in
terms of improving your life and they
looked at everything they looked at
changing your diet practicing gratitude
having a meditation practice exercising
regularly seeing your friends more all
the things that we know we should be
doing right
but do you know
that the single Behavior change that has
the biggest and most profound impact on
your quality of your day-to-day life
is simply being kinder to yourself
yeah that's right according to the
research being kinder to yourself
learning how to accept and love yourself
it is the biggest mover in terms of your
happiness meaning confidence all of it
and the sad thing about the study is
that habit of being kinder to yourself
of accepting yourself of loving yourself
it's the one we practice the least and
something that I definitely struggle
with is with masking and you know being
afraid to show up as my true authentic
self and to all people at all times yeah
just any advice would be amazing on how
to just
get better at doing that and have the
confidence to just be my authentic true
self
um all the time that would be great
um thank you Nella thank you first and
foremost for your honesty
um
but I'm gonna say something a little
provocative
you kept saying the words true authentic
self authentic self authentic self and I
want you to stop and ask yourself do you
even know who you are
do you know what it means
when you say I am my true authentic self
and the reason why I'm asking you this
question is because I don't think most
people do
I think we want to be our we want to be
our authentic selves of course but what
does that even mean
you know listening to your question it
reminds me when I was writing the high
five habit there was a woman who wrote
To Me from Ireland and I ended up
getting on the phone and then on a zoom
call and I spent a lot of time talking
to her and she is in the book and I want
to bring this up because I want to make
a point about the pressure that we feel
to conform
so in this example of the woman from
Ireland she was writing about the fact
that she wanted to get a divorce
that is her true authentic self
yet she had been delaying doing this for
seven years because of the pressure of
the Catholic church because of the
disappointment of her mother because of
what the priest might think because of
what the whole freaking country of
Ireland might think
and so I'm highlighting this because for
some of us people pleasing is even
deeper than sort of this discomfort it's
the social Norm
like you wouldn't be caught dead
In some cultures or in some religions or
in some households veering from the norm
the pressure is so intense it's just the
air that you breathe
and for many people that is the case and
so if that's you
you might not even know what the
authentic you is because you have been
told for so long by your country by your
religion by your family by the community
you live in buy whatever
who you're supposed to be
and I'm gonna give you a really
important exercise I want you to just
imagine that you are a screenwriter
that you are about to write a movie
about the real you
write a character description
and describe a day in the life of the
real you
remove the country you live in remove
the religion you grew up with or you
didn't remove the stories that you've
been telling yourself or the pressure
you feel or the disappointment or what
other people think you should or
shouldn't do
and write the story a day in the life
of who you are at your core
when you would wake up where you would
live
where you would go what kind of work you
do what kind of friends that you have
what are your habits what do you love
doing who are you laughing with
this is such an important exercise
because again remember I told you that
people pleasing
it's a balance
and it begins with you truly knowing
yourself
and if you don't really know who you are
because you've always been told who to
be and you've spent your life feeling
like you do nothing but conforming this
is a really important step for you to
take
because people pleasing at its core is
you believing the person that you are
deep inside that it's not good enough
you're not good enough
and based on what we've talked about you
can start to change that but you really
have to go through the steps of getting
curious about who you are for real
change isn't easy
I wish it were
easy
it is easy to identify friction it is
easy to identify your excuses it is easy
to identify the actions that you need to
take
but taking those actions
and feeling the emotions that come up
and dealing with people's reactions
that's not easy
and it's really important for you to
accept that and for me to accept that
because when you accept the fact
that change isn't easy but it's possible
and it's worth it
and you're capable of it
that's the truth you got to stop
comparing yourself to people whose lives
don't look like yours
you will never be able to achieve what
somebody who is a single male can
achieve because you've got other demands
on your time right now you will never be
able to achieve what a 23 year old can
do right now because you've got aging
parents and three kids and a business to
run
and so please
please stop making yourself feel like
because you are looking at somebody who
has totally different life circumstances
than you and by the way this does not
mean that there's something wrong with a
23 year old Fitness influencer I think
that's freaking fantastic that
somebody's doing that with their life
there's nothing wrong with somebody who
is going on a book tour for three months
I think that's fantastic and there's
clearly a part of me that wants to do
more of that but at the moment
I gotta face reality and the reality is
based on my values based on what life
looks like right now
I'm not going to do that but what I can
do is figure out what advice I respond
to what changes I want to make and then
I can fit that into my life I want to
become empowered to improve my work
situation so I want to ask you about
unhealthy work environments and the side
effects they manifest where should I
start making changes well one thing I
want to acknowledge really quickly is
that you do have the power to change
this because positive energy is also
very contagious and if you protect your
energy you can take proactive steps to
call people out on their behavior and so
that's what we're going to talk about
now and I want to bring a study into
this because there was a new study by
the workforce Institute at ukg that
found that 69 of people say that their
managers
have the greatest impact on their Mental
Health
that their managers had the same level
of impact on their mental health as
their partner or spouse at home
now this was more than the impact that
their doctor or therapist had on their
mental health and this was a huge study
they looked at 3 400 people across 10
countries and so you are right negative
people at work particularly a manager
really bad for your mental health
because you can't fix them
and for me there are two types of jerks
out there and we've already started to
kind of unpack this but I really want to
highlight this for you there are the
jerks that are just entitled like I
believe the woman at the hotel front
desk was that she just thinks she's
better than everybody else and they
treat people like crap because they've
always treated people like crap you know
people like this they're rude to waiters
they're short with other people they're
full of themselves they have a tone to
their voice their super pompous we hate
these kind of people the kind of people
that are rude for no reason other than
because this is how they are and this is
how they treat people and I hate people
like this and you know what else I can't
stand I can't stand the fact that they
tend to bully us right and we just give
in
and it just perpetuates this
people get a better room because they're
mean to the person at the front desk the
world should not work like this but it
drains our energy that's why we give in
and so there's that type of jerk and
then there's the second type which is
more like the person in that coffee shop
that I was explaining where they're just
under pressure
and they can't tolerate the discomfort
that they feel I call these kind of
people emotionally immature
and I use the word immature because they
throw Tantrums they're like a child who
is so frustrated so they throw
themselves on the floor
and they're immature because they do not
have a mature
or responsible way
of tolerating emotional stress
and so in these situations at work
you have a couple choices number one
we've already talked about the snow
globe this one works like a charm
because it gives you objectivity allows
you to visualize the Tantrum
and it makes you feel a little bit
better than the person honestly and so
that's one thing a second thing that you
can do is you are allowed to call people
out on this Behavior
in the first question that we got you
heard the example of somebody getting a
really rude email there's nothing wrong
with picking up the phone
or walking down the hall
and saying
hey is something going on with you
because I don't know if you know how the
tone of this email comes across
but it doesn't feel good
and most people when you call them out
on that and you kind of start off with
hey is something going on with you
because this isn't like you and the tone
is really demeaning
and is there something you want to tell
me or are you unaware that this is like
how you're speaking to people
that is the way that you can call
somebody out and obviously if you have
somebody that is engaging in this
consistently document it go to HR
because you shouldn't be under a barrage
of that kind of abusive language or
demeaning language or that sort of like
really
unnecessary pressure that's not why
you're in your job and so you can go to
HR but you know you can walk down the
hall you can pick up the phone and you
can say I'm more than happy to help you
with these things but only if you speak
to me in a respectful Manner and this is
not respectful
and I'm sorry you're having a bad day
but don't take it out on me my son
actually used to say that to me instead
of my kids they would literally go I
don't know what's going on at work but
don't take it out on me I don't work
with you and so
call the person out and if you're not
comfortable start documenting it and
then go to HR and try to
get some help with it one of the best
places to start is by
adding a simple Habit to your morning
routine
or your evening routine which is to
write down five things that you want
they can be small they can be big
anything so let me see if I can get the
three steps to developing synchronicity
as a superpower in your life number one
you have to supercharge your attention
about what you want and if you don't
know what you want start writing five
dreams down every damn day and if you
want help with that go to melrobbins.com
stream big we've got a sheet that
thousands of you have already downloaded
that'll walk you through how to do this
make this a practice because this all
begins with what's inside your mind
inside your heart and so you gotta get
serious
about putting your attention on what you
want instead of bitching about the
things that you don't have or the way
that things are so super powering your
attention is Step number one
for developing synchronicity in your
life correct yep yep okay great so step
number two Professor Myers if I'm
getting this is opening up your heart
to those moments where now that you have
supercharged your attention and said I
want that damn Gucci handbag I don't
care that it's sold out I don't care
that this or I want friends I need more
friends in my life I'm lonely
so you supercharge your attention to
what you want and then you got to be
open
to the in the beginning coincidences
that you could easily be like
that's the way that my phone listens to
me and it's serving up ads or oh that
person's just reaching out because they
want something you got to get rid of
your negative filter on what's happening
around you and you gotta wake the hell
up and realize that all around you Dr
Myers is here to profess people he has
researched this all around you are
magical connections and it's connected
to what you want inside you and the
second is in the emotion that comes with
that you you feel yes feel it yes and so
you gotta start to get positive
and intentional about calling out these
signs that life is trying to help you
that things are going in the right
direction you gotta grab one little
thing and use it as like a little toe
hold to hold on to and then when you
call out that sign you got to walk
toward it yeah
yeah is that right yeah you know I never
realized that this is how I live my life
like I think what I've learned in this
conversation is that synchronicity is
something that I've been tapping into
for a very long time and there are
periods in my life where I wasn't
tapping into it and I was completely out
of alignment and it was full of friction
and self-destruction and then there have
been periods where I've allowed myself
to say what I want or at least say what
wasn't working
and
I allowed myself to start to believe in
the signs that would be presented and
having done a tremendous amount of
research about the reticular activity
system and the filter in our brains and
how you can change your mind and how
your mind can help you
I really hope that as you're listening
to this conversation yes you I'm talking
to you
that you will open your heart and your
mind to this because it's very real I
mean they wouldn't be given the Nobel
Prize to somebody doing quantum
entanglement if two particles a light
year away could not like impact one
another and I want you to realize the
power of your thoughts and you to
realize that the world is trying to help
you that you are meant to live in
alignment that synchronicity is not only
possible it's something that you're
wired to do
and you can start today one act of
kindness from one person
can change somebody's entire life
and you have that power and so I want
you to think as you head into your day
about the image of blowing bubbles you
know when a kid is blowing bubbles and
the bubbles catch the sunlight and they
float around and they fly away it feels
so good doesn't it it makes you smile
and you can stand there on a beautiful
sunny day and blow bubbles and they
drift off into space and who knows how
far they go
your energy is just like that and you
can spread good energy and you should
how do you do that
be generous with the I love yous
be super generous telling people I
appreciate you in fact I have a habit
every single day
I make it a habit to tell somebody
that I appreciate them and I do that by
either reaching out to a friend
and telling them that I miss them and
I'm thinking about them I have a friend
who's going through a really challenging
moment right now with her dad hospice
has been called in and I'm texting her
every morning telling her that I'm
sending her a hug and that she doesn't
need to text me back but I just want her
to know that I'm here for her
I tell that to people that help me in
the grocery store I tell it to anybody
honestly because we all need to hear it
thank you for helping me thank you for
being here I love complimenting people's
nails or their jewelry or their
hairstyle or their socks and smiling
smiling and don't forget your family
when somebody walks in the door how do
you greet them
do you put a big smile on your face do
you run to the door do you say welcome
home oh my God I hope you had a great
day I always always always give our son
Oakley the biggest hug and I hold it
extra tight and I tell him I'm so happy
to see him
because every time you do this
you smile you wave you high-five
somebody you give them a hug you tell
them that you love them you text
somebody out of the blue you are a Force
for good
if you're staying in a hotel like I'm
gonna be tonight leave a note for the
person that's cleaning your room a thank
you a smiley face tell them you
appreciate them we all need to hear it
and when you become radically generous
with your positive energy with your
compliments with your enthusiasm With
Your Love
it spreads
unbelievable waves of joy and positivity
lifting people up in ways that you'll
never know every single day make it a
habit to text a friend
just out of the blue
and if you want to amplify this
take a selfie video
hey I'm just on my walk and I was
thinking of you and hey my dog says
hello and
you not only underestimate
how much people like you you
underestimate how much it means to
somebody when they hear from you
this isn't just me
this is research that was covered in the
New York Times recently about how
receiving an unexpected text from a
friend
makes you immediately feel connected to
that person and it makes the Friendship
stronger
make it a practice every single day as
you start your day to reach out to one
friend with a random message I want to
tell you I love you
I believe in you
and I believe in your ability
to stop telling yourself these lies and
to really embrace the truth
the truth is you deserve amazing
friendships you need amazing friendships
and you
are that amazing friend that somebody
who is going through a very lonely
season digging their way to a new life
needs desperately right now in terms of
my own experience with getting serious
about creating the skill of confidence
is it's a game changer the more that you
build confidence in your life the
greater the risks you're going to take
and that's critical in business in life
for fulfillment I also have the ability
to say no and not even be bothered by
what other people are going to feel why
because I have the skill of confidence
it also makes you an incredible
negotiator because you realize you would
rather be respected than be liked and
see this kind of need to be liked or to
look good is part of the reason why you
doubt yourself all the time I want you
to bring that power back internally
that's what the skill of confidence does
and you'll also be able to recognize
when you're afraid of something and that
that fear is just kind of [__] in
your head and you have a choice you
don't have to let fear stop you anymore
and that's where the skill of confidence
comes in and the same is going to be
true for you not everybody is meant to
be your friend and the second that it
feels like a force be flexible okay
here's one of the things that I love to
think about is that you can be the whole
package but if you're delivered to the
wrong address not gonna work another
quote that I've seen that I just love is
you could be the most amazing juicy end
of summer ripe Peach
but if you don't like beaches you're not
going to be a fit for that person
doesn't matter how good you are remember
flexibility
I want you to understand this because
when you tell yourself oh I got to be
liked by everybody everybody's got to
like me I got to be everybody's friend
that lie turns you into people pleaser
that lie is why you are in your head
going do they like me how do I need to
change I know I'm a peach and they don't
like peaches but maybe if I disguise
myself as a plum they'll actually like
me stop doing that embrace the fact that
you're a peach embrace your whole
package and stop forcing yourself to be
liked by everybody the reason why this
lie is so important to catch is because
there's nothing wrong with you
the more you Embrace who you are the
more you're honest about what works for
you the more you show up as your full
self imagine that imagine assuming that
people dislike you that juicy Peach that
you are as you are
imagine if you just assume imagine if
you're flexible imagine who might show
up
somebody who likes peaches wouldn't that
be a wonderful change
that's why you got to catch that because
this is about energy this is about you
and where you are in your life and where
you're going matching with beautiful
human beings that are on that same leg
of the journey with you that's what this
is about so be flexible and man you are
a juicy Peach Embrace that stuff a study
suggests that when you use an alter ego
or you create a vision of the future you
the person you want to become it gives
you distance from the scaredy cat you
who's never done this thing before so
ask yourself you know why what I always
ask myself I go well what would the rock
do in this situation I just love Dwayne
Johnson The Rock I constantly use him as
my avatar when it comes to confidence
what would the rock do in this moment
and I always get an answer and it feels
less personal because you and I are
friends you can use the rock you can use
me what would Mel do if you're feeling
unsure and you want to tap into the
confidence that you kind of pick up on
for me and this also Taps into a entire
body of research that I talk about a lot
on the Mel Robbins podcast which is
behavioral activation therapy Decades of
research show that when you start acting
like the person you want to become in
the future now
in your present life it's one of the
fastest ways for you to change your
mindset for you to create new habits why
because when you start acting like the
person you want to become in the future
you start acting like that person today
what are you doing you're trying
you're trying to act like the future you
would act none of what you're doing is a
choice
you are stuck in Old patterns based on
your childhood you're scared to death of
people leaving you
and your feelings and your fears are
making you so hesitant and the other
reason why this is not a choice is you
deeply believe you're not worthy of love
and so you don't know how to act as
though you deserve it
and so if you want to quote be me
use me as an avatar and when you start
to get those feelings coming up in your
body like I can't do this just be like
what the [__] would Mel say
because here's I'm not right or wrong
and this is your life Brooke so you got
to decide what's right for you but I
will tell you if you stay in that
feeling emotional space if I can't do
this I don't know what to say
you're just going to continue to have
the same thing
but if you want something
different
you gotta show up and act in a different
way my personal experience is that I
think it took me
decades to heal
because I became so good
at talking about my anxiety and
intellectualizing my anxiety and talking
about what happened to me and how it
made me feel and all of that was helpful
so that I was aware of what happened I
was aware of what I was feeling and I
also from that level was able to come up
with ways to cope whether that was yoga
or taking anxiety medication or it was
getting into therapy but
I wasn't doing the work to truly heal
the root cause of the anxiety and it
wasn't until I stopped talking about it
and I got below the neck
and started dealing with the
uncomfortable feelings and the stored
memories in my nervous system
which is very different than talking
about how you feel getting into your
body and feeling that kink in the
nervous system
that memory that you wish that you could
forget
that is when I truly
flip the pancake so to speak and started
to change for real
do not let the fact that you have spent
a certain amount of time or you're a
certain age or you're too early or
you're too late or all of that crap to
invalidate the truth the truth is you're
right on time
if you're having the wake-up call that I
intend for you to have as you listen to
this as you're realizing that your
dreams are as alive as they have ever
been
if you are starting to go oh my god I've
been against myself
I'm going to be for myself
if you're starting to say wow I really
have put the lid on I really have
stopped allowing myself for giving
myself permission to have something
incredible happen in my life
if you're having the wake-up call that I
intended good now let me tell you
something else there is no deadline on
your dreams and there is no age at which
you're supposed to do this
you can start a business at 18. you can
quit the job you had out of college at
24. you can go back to technical school
after getting a master's at 31. you can
literally adopt a child at the age of 39
when you're single you can go to nursing
school after you've raised your kids and
you're 42 years old you can learn how to
teach your first online course at the
age of 48 you could become a podcast
host at the age of 54. you could get
married for the first time at 63. you
could Skydive at 71. you could run your
first marathon at 82.
your dreams do not disappear
there is no age at when you can't do
something or when you're too early it's
complete [__] your dreams are
something you were born with they are
your responsibility and they are also
the life force inside of you so stop
running away from them and turn toward
them run toward your dreams stop arguing
against them and be the loudest voice
for them and for crying out loud stop
extinguishing
that flame that's burning inside you
enough with the excuses enough with the
jokes and the downplaying enough
with this fear
your job
is to turn toward that flame
turn toward that flame and freaking fan
it
fan it with all your might
that flame inside you is supposed to
burn bright
and the only way that that's going to
happen is when you are honest with
yourself about that thing you've been
denying about that calling that you feel
about the fact that you're meant for
more than where you're at right now that
you deserve to be happy that those
dreams are real and you have within you
the ability to chip away at them and
that when you wake up every single day
and you write down those five dreams and
you see and you hear and you feel the
fact that your life
has Clues your life is trying to help
you
your life is trying to help you become
who you're destined to become
I want you to know something
you're going to wake up happier every
day
you're going to wake up feeling more
alive and more self-expressed and more
connected and energized when you wake up
for your dreams one of the things that I
notice can happen when you are in a
period in your life where you're trying
to heal you're investing in yourself and
your personal growth you mentioned that
you're working on trauma you're trying
to dig out of some of the holes maybe
that you feel like you fell into you're
trying to change your mindset that's
serious work that was me for years too
here's the problem with having a big
healing Journey
you're not having any fun I think about
periods of my life when I was going
through a lot of change and I was
working on myself and I was doing
everything that you're doing every book
I picked up was self-help everything
that I listen to is self-improvement I
couldn't even remember the last time I
read a fiction novel or I went to a
concert or I went to a party everything
got so serious because my focus became
so serious and my focus was about
improving my life improving my life
improving my life and doing the work to
change your life it's important doing
the work to identify toxic patterns that
you have or bad thinking patterns that
make you feel like that's super
important
but you must also double down on the fun
while you're doing the deeper work and
so the first thing that I want you to do
is I want you to set an intention
that your number one goal this year is
to have more fun
to invest in that first category hedonic
happiness that researchers say is so
important because yes it's meaningful
yes it's fulfilling to do the hard work
to change your life for the better but
changing your life for the better also
means that you need more moments of fun
in your life motivation is garbage
yep
Mel Robbins
one of the most successful motivational
speakers in the world just said
motivation is garbage
you see you're making the same mistake
we all make when we think about
motivation you're waiting to feel
motivated first before you take action
and you've been told a lie about
motivation so you've been made to
believe that you got to feel motivated
that that feeling that emotion is going
to come before the action it's actually
the opposite you got to take action and
the motivation comes
and that's why the first takeaway
is motivation is garbage because my
definition of motivation is that it's
just a feeling and it comes and it goes
okay that's the way that you've been
using it and the irony is you need
motivation motivation is fundamental you
need this desire to move in order to
finish a project you gotta have
motivation to get out of bed to move off
the couch to head to that networking
meeting and I know that you felt
motivated before you felt motivated when
you're on a team and uh lots of people
are yelling at you you've felt motivated
when you need to pay your bills but the
truth is when you're alone and you got
something that you need to do that's
hard or that's I don't know gonna
require some effort if it scares you a
little bit or it's going to put you out
there guess what's not going to be there
motivation
you're going to come up with every
excuse in the book why you shouldn't
make your calls why you shouldn't go to
the gym why you don't feel like going
out of bed
and that's because if you rely on the
feeling of motivation first you're
waiting for something that's never going
to come
that's why you've spent years thinking
about what you need to do instead of
just doing what you need to do
waiting for motivation is a trap
because you're never going to feel like
doing the things you need to do to
create a better life period it's a
message everybody needs to hear because
there's only one thing
I want you to do this week
nothing
do nothing
wait a minute
Mel Robbins
are you smoking something over there did
you just say do nothing
and here's the funny part about this
I bet you might be doing something right
now because you're a multitasker and so
am I you're listening to me while you're
doing the dishes while you're walking
the dogs heck you and I might be at the
point in our relationship where you are
actually sitting on the toilet and I'm
in the bathroom stall with you as you're
listening to this don't tell me that you
have not taken me into the bathroom
because I can even feel it over here
and I say this because we got to talk
about the art of doing nothing and look
I'm not stupid enough to think that you
can actually do nothing I mean obviously
not this is like a metaphorical
conversation because you probably have
to work I personally love working
between the week of Christmas and New
Year because nobody's there so you can
kind of like work half a day and you get
the full-time pay and it's way more
stress free and you can get more done
because you aren't in a million meetings
but if you do have the time off
let me guess
what are you doing with the time off
you're rearranging your cupboards you're
probably trying to learn Spanish you're
doing a million things on your to-do
list you are like just keeping busy
this week
just stop
please
I want to explain this concept this
metaphor of doing nothing
being able to do nothing whether it's
just for a minute
or it's for a day or it's for a week
this is so important and I'm having the
conversation not only with you I am
talking to myself right now too
I have a hard time doing nothing why
well because I'm just like you I'm
addicted to being busy I'm addicted to
my to-do list writing them out Crossing
them off throwing them away losing them
writing another one especially in the
world today
the world has glamorized being
productive being busy go go go hustles
hustle culture having a side hustle I
mean there's so much to hustle around
some days I literally have no idea what
I'm doing
you may always be on the go like I am
but are you actually getting anywhere
manifesting is intentionally
training your brain and your nervous
system to believe in something that
hasn't happened yet
that's what manifesting is
manifesting is a power tool it's backed
by Neuroscience it is backed by years of
research and when used properly
it helps you achieve your goals because
it helps you prepare to do the work I
use
science-backed manifesting tools every
single day to shut down the negative
conversations in my life and to live a
big life and to take big risks and dude
Olympic athletes use manifesting and
we're going to get into how Olympic
athletes and the world's leading you
know Business Leaders and successful
people everywhere use it but I'm telling
you right now the way you shut down your
internal
conversation that is holding you back is
manifesting manifesting is one of the
first things you have to learn how to do
to get started on making this a reality
so what is manifesting manifesting is
mentally training
forgetting what you want that's all that
it is it is part of the toolkit that
successful people around the world use
let me tell you what manifesting is not
manifesting is not thinking thoughts and
then hoping they come through
that is what people do on their seventh
birthday and they blow out the candles
that is not what we are doing here
manifesting is based in neuroscience it
is a tool that you are going to use
precisely intentionally systematically
with purpose
because you use manifesting to re-wire
your mind and your body and your spirit
to help you do the work to achieve your
dreams
when you use manifesting properly
you are removing the mental obstacles of
self-doubt resistance fear perfectionism
feeling overwhelmed other people's
expectations all that stuff that is
holding you in place right now that
makes you spin in circles manifest and
clears that [__] out and it programs
using science a completely different way
of thinking and feeling about the things
that you want to create in your life and
when you manifest properly it's almost
like the pregame training that you do
before the big game It prepares you to
take action it boosts your confidence it
gets you ready to do that thing part of
creating a better life is having moments
that you're going to have to navigate
where you get triggered by something
stupid or something profound and all
these emotions come up and you say fit
and I do not want you to give up in
those moments I do not want you to throw
in the towel or throw out the Christmas
cards or say I can't do it I mean that's
what I did yesterday I felt that huge
wave I said that's it it I came up into
the office and I started crying and I
said to the team I can't do this I can't
talk about habits I can't I can't even
get Christmas cards out in the mail I
can't do this I went to my husband and
my daughter and I said I'm not doing 75
hard I got too much going on I this is
not the time for me to do this like I'm
setting myself for failure and you know
what they said they said yes you can
yes you can
and they sat there and they listened to
me wine and wine and wine and Chris
looked at me and he said Mel
you gotta have a breakthrough
you have to take on something that feels
hard and you have to do it for longer
than the month or the you know 45 days
that you've done it in the past
and right now is the perfect time the
fact that you're feeling the [__] it
just four days in this is a good thing
Mel because it's pushing buttons in you
and so
what was interesting
because it's pushing buttons on you and
you know what he's right
he's absolutely right and so I went to
bed
like immediately I didn't even want to
tempt myself because I was so frazzled I
went to bed I slept all night and when I
woke up this morning and came up to work
what was so interesting
is that life doesn't always
give you what you want
but it does give you what you need
and I think at moments sometimes are
what you need
because you need to see
that you can have a moment where you
want to give up
and you can even screw up in those
moments
and you can get back on the
transformation train and you can keep
going
that you are bigger than the moment that
the [__] moment is there to test you
it's there because it's part of the
process of growing how you create a
better life with goal setting because
goals setting from this point forward
must be a part of your life if you want
to feel a greater sense of purpose and
meaning period
and so I want you to come back to this
episode I want you to bookmark it I want
you to share this with people that you
care about if you've got somebody like I
do who's a college senior and as they
approach graduation and they start to
feel like they're about to have a
quarter life crisis and they're lost you
know what they need they need goals if
you have a friend going through divorce
you know what they need they need goals
if you're bored in Life or feeling stuck
or you've got to hit the reinvention
button you know what you need you need
goals and you can re-listen to this
every single quarter at any moment in
your life and walk yourself through this
very simple but powerful and
life-changing research to get very clear
about what you want and why you want it
and how you're going to go achieve it
now speaking about the how
you want to know how
habits are how you achieve goals systems
are how you make it easier because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Marine forleo inspiration
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there bigger isn't
better and more isn't better when it
comes to work life balance the more that
you shut down and kind of check out and
give yourself time and space you come
back and you realize you actually didn't
miss anything all you missed was a lot
of noise